THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
WILL COME TO ORDER AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I SEE ONE
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM. RIGHT. SO WE
WILL START WITH ITEM. 8AB 2729.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND,
SENATOR, FOR, HEARING MY BILL,
THIS AFTERNOON AND BUSY DAY, AS
YOU KNOW, AB 2729, WAS AMENDED
OR PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OFFERED
TODAY, AB 2729 WOULD DO TWO
THINGS. ONE IS IT WOULD DEFER
THE PAYMENT OF IMPACT FEES ON
CERTAIN TYPES OF DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. AND THEN SECONDLY, IT
WOULD EXTEND BY 18 MONTHS.
ENTITLEMENTS THAT ARE EXPIRING
OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD, AND THAT
WILL APPLY TO, TO ALL PROJECTS.
AND SO PRETTY SIMPLE. PRETTY
SIMPLE. BILL, WE OBVIOUSLY SPENT
A LOT OF TIME ON IT IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE AND, HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS, OBVIOUSLY. AND
WITH ME, I DO HAVE SOME SUPPORT,
TO TESTIFY ON MY BEHALF. HOLLY
FROM DEJESUS WHISPER. GREAT. YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF SPUR
, WHO HAS BEEN A PROUD SPONSOR
AND CO-SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER OF
NUMEROUS BILLS THAT HAVE PASSED
SINCE 2017 THAT AIM AT
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
ESPECIALLY BY STREAMLINING LOCAL
PROJECT APPROVALS, ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND INCREASING
ENFORCEABILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH STATE
HOUSING LAWS, AS WELL AS
CREATING MORE TRANSPARENCY WITH
IMPACT FEES. ALL PROJECTS ARE
NOW STRUGGLING TO SECURE
FINANCING IN A TIMELY MANNER, IN
A TIMELY MANNER. DUE TO THE
RECENT CHANGES IN ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS YOU ALL CAN'T CONTROL,
BUT WHAT YOU CAN'T CONTROL IS
TIME. AND TIME IS MONEY. SO
DEFERRING IMPACT FEES, PAYMENTS
AS WELL AS ENTITLEMENT
EXTENSIONS IS GOING TO SAVE
PROJECTS MONEY. AND WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? STEPHEN CENSOR WITH
BROWN SEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT GREAT. ANY OTHERS?
BROOKE PRITCHARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT.
RAFA SONNENFELD WITH MBA ACTION
IN SUPPORT. OKAY. ARE YOU GOING
TO READ SOME? GO AHEAD. ONE MORE
I FORGOT ON BEHALF OF FIELDSTEAD
AND ASSOCIATES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE
A, ANY MAJOR OPPOSITION HERE
REGISTERED? I DON'T THINK WE DO.
BUT IN CASE THERE ARE. OH, YES,
YOU'RE RIGHT. WE HAVE THE
SPECIAL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION AND
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. GO
AHEAD. YES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY GIRTON ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE, GIVEN
THE CONCERNS THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED, THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT FEES EARLIER AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE ELIMINATED IN SOME
SITUATIONS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS, AS WE'VE
STATED IN THE LOCAL GOVT
COMMITTEE, ONE OF OUR MAJOR
CONCERNS IS IF WE HAVE MULTIPLE
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING DELAYED
FOR CONSTRUCTION, THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
FACILITIES UP AND READY TO GO
FOR NEW RESIDENTS MOVING INTO
THE AREA. SO WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT THE ABILITY TO DELAY THE
COLLECTION WILL HAVE AN UNDUE
HARM TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY THE DEVELOPMENT AND
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES. SO
WITH THAT, WE ARE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS. WE THINK THAT
NARROWING IT IS HELPFUL, BUT OUR
Dð ARE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACTS TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SPECIAL DISTRICTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
ANTHONY TANNEHILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. I ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE PRIOR SPEAKER, MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LEAGUE, THIS
MEASURE DOES, SEVERAL THINGS
THAT CAN BE ONEROUS TO THE
DELIVERY OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO SERVICE
THE DEVELOPMENT, IT PROHIBITS
THE COLLECTION OF INTEREST ON
THE DEFERRED FEES. IT DOESN'T
CONTEMPLATE INDEXING IT FOR
INFLATION, IF A PROJECT TAKES,
YOU KNOW, A QUITE A WHILE TO, TO
COMPLETE AND WE WANT TO HAVE
THOSE SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE UP AND RUNNING
AND AVAILABLE FOR THAT
COMMUNITY, NOT HAVING IT
INDEXED, OR AN AVENUE TO COLLECT
THAT AND HAVING IT OPEN ENDED
WITH NO, NO CAP ON HOW LONG THE
PROJECT CAN RUN. IT WANTS THE
FEES ARE LOCKED IN. I THINK
THESE ARE INTERESTING THINGS TO
CONSIDER. I DO APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK. BUT AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE MITIGATION FEE ACT
DOES ALREADY CONTEMPLATE
ACCOUNTING FOR THESE FUNDS AND
HOW LONG THEY CAN SIT THERE AND
HAS MECHANISMS FOR REFUNDS AND
ALL THIS, IT'S NOT THE REALLY
FINE POINTED, SHOT CLOCK THAT
THIS MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS, BUT
I THINK IT'S WORTHWHILE
CONSIDERING THAT IT'S ALREADY
BEEN CONTEMPLATED HERE. AND WITH
THAT, I'LL JUST AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY REGISTER MY
OPPOSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. ALICE IS STILL HIGH ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD,
THE CITY OF BELMONT, AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS
ALSO OPPOSED FOR REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SASHA HOROWITZ WITH
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING, IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM?
OKAY. COLLEAGUES ON THE DAIS GO
AHEAD, SENATOR SUGIARTO. WELL, I
MADE SIMILAR COMMENTS IN THE
OTHER, OTHER COMMITTEE MEETING,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I HEAR THE ISSUES
THAT THE LEAGUE AND THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND SOME OF THE CITIES
HAVE, BUT IF YOU REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE,
THERE'S DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
MITIGATION FEES AND CONDITIONS
OF APPROVAL, USUALLY THE
MITIGATION FEES ARE FOR A, A, A
MAJOR ARTERIAL OR A FIRE STATION
THAT REQUIRES SEVERAL PROJECTS
TO PUT INTO THE MITIGATION FUND
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN BE BUILT.
AND SO IT IS ALONG THOSE
TIMELINES THAT THAT GETS DONE,
IF THERE IS IMMEDIATE NEED STUFF
THAT'S CALLED A CONDITIONS OF
APPROVAL. AND THAT'S WHERE THE
THEY DO PAY UP FRONT. AND THIS
DOESN'T PREVENT THEM. IF THEY
HAVE A PROJECT THEY WANT TO DO,
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN, IF THEY DO
HAVE A PROJECT THAT IS NEEDING
THESE FUNDS, THEY CAN GET THEM
IMMEDIATELY SO THAT THEY CAN
EMBARK ON DOING THAT PROJECT, IT
ALSO SERVES, YOU KNOW, FROM
ANOTHER PART OF THIS IS THERE'S
ALWAYS COMPLAINTS THAT IT'S
TAKING TOO LONG TO GET THROUGH
THE PROCESS, AND THE INSPECTORS
COME OUT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WELL, THIS WOULD REMOVE ANY
INCENTIVE THE CITY WOULD HAVE AT
ALL, BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
PROJECT IS THEIR MITIGATION FEES
AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT GET
TO BE COLLECTED. SO WHAT THIS
REALLY IS, IS AN ISSUE OF DO YOU
COLLECT IT IN FRONT AND THE CITY
GETS THE INTEREST ON ALL OF THAT
MONEY OR DO YOU COLLECT IT IN
THE BACK WHEN THE ACTUAL
MITIGATION NEEDS TO START AND
ALLOW THE DEVELOPER TO ENSURE
THAT HE HAS A CASH FLOW OR THAT
PERSON HAS A CASH FLOW TO MAKE
THE DEVELOPMENT WORK AND BRING
IT TO FRUITION BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THESE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES
CAN BE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT. AND
WHEN THAT'S THE CASE, IF THERE'S
A CASH FLOW ISSUE THAT CAN STALL
THE PROJECT IN AND OF ITSELF. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY GOOD BILL. I AM
SUPPORTING THIS. I USUALLY, YOU
KNOW, KIND OF GIVE DEFERENCE TO
THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES, BUT
THEY'RE NOT MISSING OUT ON THEIR
MITIGATION FEES. AND TO SAY
THAT, YOU KNOW, HEY, WE'RE
MISSING OUT ON THE INTEREST.
WELL, THAT'S NOT REALLY YOUR
MONEY TO MAKE INTEREST ON YET
BECAUSE THERE'S NO MITIGATION
NEEDED YET. SO, SO WITH THAT,
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN WE HAVE
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WE NEED TO
FORM A QUORUM. OKAY. WE'LL WAIT
TO GET OUR QUORUM. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS ON THE DÍAS,
GO AHEAD, SENATOR CHOBOQ. SO, I
ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE, BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT, DO YOU HAVE ANY, IDEA ON
WHETHER OR NOT THIS MIGHT
ACTUALLY, INCENTIVIZE OR
MOTIVATE THE CITIES TO ACTUALLY
CARRY THROUGH THE PROCESS AS
WELL? I KNOW THAT THERE'S
VARIOUS INSPECTION PERIODS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY HAVE TO
DO. DO YOU THINK THIS MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE A LITTLE MORE, ALSO
BE IMPACTING THE EFFECTIVENESS
AND THE EFFICIENCY MORE
EFFICIENCY OF MOVING THE
PROJECTS FORWARD? WELL, THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION, IN A
SHORT WAY, YES. I MEAN, I SERVED
ON A CITY COUNCIL, BY THE WAY.
I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
NEEDS OF THE CITY. AND EVEN IN
MY OWN CITY, WHEN I WAS MOVING
MY DISTRICT OFFICE, ONCE I WAS
ELECTED TO THE LEGISLATURE, YOU
KNOW, THINGS TOOK A LOT LONGER
THAN NEEDED TO BE. AND MAYBE THE
PAYMENT OF FEES WHEN THE, YOU
KNOW, ALL THE INSPECTIONS AND
STUFF ARE DONE, ACTUALLY MIGHT
HAVE MOVED THAT, ALONG A LITTLE
BIT QUICKER, BUT, YEAH, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE I THINK IT
CREATES THE RIGHT TYPES OF
INCENTIVES. AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HAVE
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF THERE ARE
EXPENDITURES MADE OR THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WHERE, YOU KNOW, THE CITY IS OUT
OF MONEY, BASICALLY, FOR SOME
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING RELATIVE
TO THE PROJECT THAT THEY CAN
GET, THEY CAN GET THE MONEY. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
BEFORE I HAVE YOU CLOSE, I THINK
THE, WELL, I APPRECIATE THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS CONCERNS AND
THE CITY'S CONCERNS. IF, FOR
EXAMPLE, A PROJECT DID NOT
PROCEED AND DID NOT CONSTRUCT,
THEN THE DIFFERENT ARGUMENTS
ABOUT, WELL, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN I
MEAN, YOU THE, IT'S KIND OF
INAPPROPRIATE TO START ON IT
UNTIL IT'S REALLY CLEAR THAT THE
PROJECT IS GOING TO PROCEED.
AND, SO I THINK I THINK THIS IS
REASONABLE. I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. OF COURSE, THE, THE, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WANT THAT FUNDING IN ADVANCE,
I'VE BEEN DOING A PROJECT
MYSELF, ON AND, BECAUSE OF
VARIOUS REASONS, IT WAS DELAYED
NOT IN NOT BY MY INTENTION. SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN I PAID THE
SCHOOL IMPACT FEE, TWO AND A
HALF YEARS AGO, THINKING THAT MY
PROJECT WOULD BE FINISHED IN SIX
MONTHS. SO YOU KNOW, THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY IT IS NOT YET
FINISHED. AND SO THE SCHOOLS
OBVIOUSLY HAVE NOT HAD ANY MORE
STUDENTS AS A RESULT OF MY
PROJECT, BUT THEY GOT THAT FEE
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AGO ANYWAY.
BUT I THINK THERE'S, IT'S JUST,
THERE'S ENOUGH SAFEGUARDS IN
THIS MEASURE AND IT'S NARROWED
ENOUGH. I THINK IT'S REASONABLE.
AND I HAVE A RECOMMENDED I AND
YOU MAY CLOSE. GREAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, I APPRECIATE THAT. VERY
SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND, AND THE FEES
ARE IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL IN,
TO AN EXTENT, I THINK SOME
CITIES ARE BETTER THAN OTHERS AT
COLLECTING REASONABLE FEES, AND
SOME AREN'T SO REASONABLE. BUT
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL. I DO WANT
TO COMMENT ON ONE THING
REGARDING THE INTEREST. IF YOU
DON'T MIND, I'VE I'VE HEARD THAT
FROM MY FRIENDS THAT I RESPECT
IN THE OPPOSITION. BUT IF I'M
WHEN YOU, CHAIR, WERE DOING YOUR
PROJECT AND YOU PAID IN SIX THAT
FIRST DAY UNDER EXISTING LAW,
AND YOUR PROJECT ISN'T DONE FOR
A LONG TIME. THE SPECIAL
DISTRICT AND THE CITY COLLECT
THAT FEE. AT THAT TIME, THEY
DON'T COME BACK TWO AND A HALF
YEARS LATER AND SAY, OH, HEY,
YOU GOT TO ACTUALLY PAY ME MORE
FEE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, INTEREST
AND INFLATION AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. SO THE, THE
IDEA THAT WE THAT THIS DOESN'T
CONTAIN PROVISIONS FOR THE
INCREASE IN INFLATION, WHILE THE
PROJECT GOES ON MAKES PERFECT
SENSE THAT THAT'S NOT IN THE
BILL BECAUSE IT THAT WOULD BE
TOTALLY UNFAIR IF WE CAME BACK
TO YOU, CHAIR AND SAID, HEY, YOU
SHOULD PAY MORE, MORE FEES NOW
BECAUSE IT'S TAKING A LONG TIME
TO DO THE PROJECT. SO ANYWAYS,
WITH THAT, I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF I KNOW SEVERAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE ON BOTH
COMMITTEES, AND THIS WAS A VERY
LONG DISCUSSION, AND I THINK IT
WAS WORTH IT BECAUSE WE CAME UP
WITH A BETTER PRODUCT AND REALLY
APPRECIATE, THE CONSIDERATION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, GREAT. WE DON'T HAVE
QUORUM YET, SO WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE, WE WILL TAKE A
MOTION AND VOTE. SO WE'LL NOW,
YOUR OTHER BILL WAS ON CONSENT,
SO I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU HAVE TO
PRESENT. GREAT. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. YES WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
AUTHOR. SO, GO AHEAD, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY, WE WILL HAVE YOU
PROCEED, AND THAT IS ITEM 16 AB
3068. GREAT, GREAT. AND I ALSO
HAVE, MR. SANTIAGO, YOU MAY
PROCEED ON WHICHEVER ONE YOU
WANT TO START WITH. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING AB 2910 FOR SANTIAGO.
WHICHEVER ONE. YOU SURE? I WILL
START WITH MY BILL. OKAY, GREAT.
B 38. FOR THOSE FOLLOWING. OKAY.
I WANT TO THANK THE. YOU MADAM
CHAIR, AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL AND
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. AB 3068 IS THE
OFFICE TO HOUSING CONVERSION
ACT, WHICH WILL ACCELERATE THE
TRANSFORMATION OF UNDERUTILIZED
OFFICE BUILDINGS WITHIN PRIME
LOCATIONS INTO NEW HOUSING.
DOWNTOWN'S ARE STRUGGLING. WE
KNOW THAT, OUR WORK CULTURE HAS
SHIFTED IN MANY WAYS IN
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS, IN
DOWNTOWNS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING THE EFFECTS OF HIGH
VACANCY RATES. THIS SHIFT HAS
LEFT OUR CITY'S URBAN CORES IN
TROUBLE AND IN DESPERATE NEED OF
CATALYTIC TRANSFORMATIONS THAT
WILL CREATE LIVABLE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR COMMERCIAL
DISTRICTS TO HELP OUR DOWNTOWNS
AND BUILD MORE HOUSING. AB 3068
CREATES A PATHWAY FOR, BY RIGHT
APPROVAL FOR OFFICE CONVERSION
PROJECTS, ENSURING MORE
PREDICTABILITY AND FEWER
BARRIERS TO AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
BUILDING PROCESS. IT ALSO
PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY NEEDED
TO ENSURE THE HISTORIC BUILDINGS
ARE MORE ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE
FOR CONVERSION, SO WE CAN
PRESERVE OUR BUILDINGS FOR
HOUSING WHILE MAKING SURE OUR
DOWNTOWN'S DIVERSE
CHARACTERISTICS ARE KEPT INTACT.
WE HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER A GREAT
COALITION ON THIS BILL, AND WITH
ME IN SUPPORT. TODAY IS RAFA
SONNENFELD FROM YIMBY ACTION AND
CINDY HEITZMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION. GREAT GO AHEAD, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
RAFA SONNENFELD WITH THE YIMBY
ACTION. YIMBY. ACTION IN OUR
CHAPTERS FIGHT FOR BETTER
HOUSING POLICIES BECAUSE WE WANT
TO REDUCE POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS, ELIMINATE RACIAL
SEGREGATION, CREATE JOBS, AND
STOP CLIMATE CHANGE. CONVERTING
VACANT COMMERCIAL SPACE INTO
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING THROUGH
ADAPTIVE REUSE. THROUGH THIS
BILL, AB 3068 CAN REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF UNDERUTILIZED AND
VACANT BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DECREASING IN VALUE. THEY'RE
THEREBY HELPING TO STABILIZE THE
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE MARKET
AND FILLING THOSE VACANT SPACES
WITH MORE VALUABLE TAX
GENERATING USES. ADAPTIVE REUSE
PROJECTS CAN ALSO INCREASE
ACTIVITY AND FOOT TRAFFIC IN
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE STATE,
WHICH WILL HELP SUPPORT LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND ENHANCE THE
CULTURAL LIFE OF CITIES AND
TOWNS. UNFORTUNATELY, LOCAL
DISCRETIONARY APPROVAL PROCESSES
AND ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS FOR
HOUSING CAN CAUSE YEARS LONG
DELAYS, INCREASED RISK OF
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOPMENTS,
MAKING HOUSING PROJECTS
INFEASIBLE, AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THE CHALLENGES IN RESOLVING THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. AB 3068,
THE OFFICE OF HOUSING CONVERSION
ACT PROVIDES A STREAMLINED
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
ADAPTIVE REUSE OF EXISTING
BUILDINGS INTO RESIDENTIAL USES
IN INFILL AREAS IN ALL ZONES.
THE ACT FACILITATES THE
CONVERSION OF UNDERUTILIZED
SPACE AND OFFICE AND OTHER
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
BUILDINGS INTO RESIDENTIAL USES.
IF AT LEAST 50% OF THE CONVERTED
SPACE IS USED FOR RESIDENTIAL
PURPOSES, WHILE OTHERWISE
ALLOWING THOSE BUILDINGS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR CURRENTLY ALLOWED
USES WITHOUT THE NEED FOR A
LENGTHY, RISKY DISCRETIONARY
REZONING. THE ACT ALSO PROTECTS
HISTORIC PROPERTIES, ENSURING
THAT THEIR ADAPTIVE REUSE IS
DONE IN ACCORDANCE WITH NATIONAL
BEST PRACTICES FOR HISTORIC
PRESERVATION. ADDITIONALLY, AB
3068 AUTHORIZES LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO CREATE A
PROPERTY TAX REBATE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE ADAPTIVE
REUSE OF PROJECTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. GREAT. CHAIR SKINNER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS CINDY HEITZMAN. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION. TODAY I SEEK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 3068,
CO-SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PRESERVATION FOUNDATION AND
YIMBY ACTION, AB 3068 AIMS TO
STREAMLINE THE ADAPTIVE REUSE OF
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS INTO
HOUSING. THIS LEGISLATION IS
CRUCIAL TO FACILITATE THE REUSE
OF VACANT OR UNDERUTILIZED
BUILDINGS, STIMULATE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, AND PROVIDE HOUSING
THROUGH SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT.
ADAPTIVE REUSE ISN'T JUST A
TREND, IT'S A PROVEN SOLUTION TO
CREATE HOUSING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OFFICES, HOSPITALS,
FACTORIES, AND EVEN GRAIN SILOS
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
REPURPOSED INTO HOUSING. AB 3068
WILL STREAMLINE THE REVIEW
PROCESS FOR HISTORIC RESOURCES,
MAKING IT EASIER TO DEVELOP
HOUSING WHILE PRESERVING THE
UNIQUE CHARACTER OF OUR OLDER
BUILDINGS. LOS ANGELES HAS SET A
PRECEDENT WITH ITS ADAPTIVE
REUSE ORDINANCE REVITALIZING ITS
HISTORIC CORE AND GENERATING
OVER 12,000 NEW UNITS SINCE
1999, THIS INITIATIVE HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY BOOSTED GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT, INCREASING THE
POPULATION FROM 27,849 RESIDENTS
IN 2000 TO OVER 83,000 RESIDENTS
IN JANUARY OF 2019. WHAT SETS AB
3068 APART FROM OTHER HOUSING
BILLS IS ITS STREAMLINED REVIEW
OF HISTORIC RESOURCES. THIS IS
BASED ON AGE, LANDMARK STATUS
AND ELIGIBILITY FOR FEDERAL OR
STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDITS. IT
REQUIRES COMPLIANCE WITH THE
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
STANDARDS FOR TREATMENT OF
HISTORIC PROPERTIES TO ENSURE
THAT PRESERVATION STANDARDS ARE
MET, AND THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE SOME OF THE BEST
CANDIDATES FOR ADAPTIVE REUSE
ARE OLDER HISTORIC BUILDINGS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE REHABILITATION
OF HISTORIC BUILDINGS IS A LABOR
INTENSIVE ACTIVITY, MEANING A
HIGH SHARE OF THE TOTAL
EXPENDITURES GOES TO LABOR.
THESE PROJECTS CREATE MORE
LOCALIZED JOBS COMPARED TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES. FOR
EVERY TEN DIRECT JOBS CREATED BY
REHABILITATION. BY
REHABILITATING A HISTORIC
BUILDING, ANOTHER 1.8 TO 2.4
ADDITIONAL JOBS ARE CREATED
ELSEWHERE IN THE ECONOMY. AB
3068 IS MORE THAN A HOUSING
BILL. IT'S A TOOL FOR ECONOMIC
REVITALIZATION AND PRESERVATION
BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL, WE CAN
CREATE HOUSING, STIMULATE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND PRESERVE THE
CHARACTER OF OUR HISTORIC
DOWNTOWNS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 3068. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. JUST COME UP TO THE MIC,
ADD YOUR ME TO. HI, ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM HERE. ON BEHALF OF
THE NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL INTERIOR DESIGN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. BOB NAYLOR FOR FIELDSTEAD
AND COMPANY. THAT'S HOWARD
AHMANSON JR AND ORANGE COUNTY
PHILANTHROPIST IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. REBECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING LEADINGAGE,
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT SKYLAR
WONACOTT, CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION. AND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING OWNERS
AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. BROOKE PRITCHARD, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
SUPPORT HOLLY DEJESUS WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL AND SPUR
AND SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. LET'S
SEE IF WE HAVE, REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. BRADY GIRTON, ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN A RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. FIRST,
I WANTED TO COMMEND THE AUTHORS
OFFICE. THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON ADDRESSING
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING THE FEES
SPECIFICALLY. SO WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE ON THAT. THAT SAID, CAL
CITIES IS STILL CONCERNED WITH
THE BY RIGHT APPROVAL PROCESS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT. IT'S BEEN
NARROWED TO SOME SPECIFIC SITES.
WE THINK THAT'S A PRODUCTIVE
THING, BUT OUR ARE STILL
CONCERNED THAT BY RIGHT OVER THE
COUNTER APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
AREAS NOT MEANT FOR RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING DOES NOT GIVE
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO
ADJUST WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR
AREAS THAT WERE NOT MEANT FOR
RESIDENTIAL USES IN THE PAST. SO
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
LANGUAGE AND BELIEVE THAT
THROUGH THE ARENA PROCESS, WE
SET THE SITES AVAILABLE FOR THAT
AND BY SKIPPING OUR PLANS, WE
WONDER WHAT THE POINT OF THE TEN
YEAR PLAN IS. SO THAT'S WHERE
OUR CONCERNS LIE. BUT APPRECIATE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE, JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL, WE HAVE NOT
TAKEN AN OFFICIAL OPPOSED
POSITION TO THE BILL. WE HAVE
HAD A NICE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HIS HARD
WORKING STAFF ON, PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS, HERE AGAIN, TOOTING
THAT SAME HORN, THIS IS BY
RIGHT, APPROVAL FOR ADAPTIVE
REUSE. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS INCLUSION OF
LABOR STANDARDS AT THE START. WE
NEED TO GET THOSE TWEAKED A
LITTLE BIT, A LITTLE WRITE MORE
A LITTLE MORE CORRECT. AND WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS TO THAT
EFFECT. WE APPRECIATE THAT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATIONS BEGINNING OR
CONTINUING. EXCUSE ME OVER THE
RECESS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER, OPPOSITION,
COMMENTS OR GO AHEAD. SENATOR
SEYARTO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I APPRECIATE, OUR EFFORTS TO
TRY TO EXPAND HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES. I ALSO HAVE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
OUTLINED BY THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
IN, IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES.
THERE ESPECIALLY MASTER PLAN
COMMUNITIES, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S IN THE
GROUND WAS AND THE STREET WIDTHS
AND THE AND WHERE THEY GO ARE
ALL PREDICATED ON DIFFERENT
TYPES OF USES. AND, YOU KNOW,
THESE USES, YOU KNOW, THESE
ADAPTIVE USES. I KIND OF GOT A
QUESTION. YOU KNOW, HOW ADAPTIVE
CAN SOME OF THESE BUILDINGS BE?
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE GOING FROM A
TYPE ONE CONSTRUCTION BUILDING
TO A TYPE FIVE CONSTRUCTION
BUILDING AND YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT INTERIOR HALLWAYS, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AIR HANDLING
SYSTEMS AND BEING ABLE TO, YOU
KNOW, PROVIDE ALL OF THESE
THINGS TO APARTMENTS INSIDE
WHAT'S NOW WHAT USED TO BE A
COMMERCIAL BUILDING, AND, AND
YOU KNOW, PUTTING WINDOWS INTO,
YOU KNOW, CONCRETE STRUCTURES
THAT ARE SIX, 6 TO 8IN WIDE, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THAT CHANGES THE
DYNAMICS OF THE SAFETY PART OF
IT. AND THAT'S WHY I GET A
LITTLE NERVOUS WHEN WE'RE
STREAMLINING, YOU KNOW, IF IT
CAN BE DONE, THAT'S GREAT. BUT
BY RIGHT AND STREAMLINE FOR SUCH
A THOSE ARE INTENSIVE CHANGES TO
BUILDINGS. AND A LOT OF IT HAS
TO DO WITH LIFE SAFETY STUFF.
AND, AND SO I GET A LITTLE
NERVOUS WHEN WE'RE BY WRITING
ALL THESE AND BYPASSING THE
LOCAL AGENCIES ABILITY TO WEIGH
IN AND WEIGH IN HEAVILY ON SOME
OF THIS, BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
HOLDING THE BAG IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE SEEN
FIRES IN SOME OF THESE AREAS
THAT THEY CHANGE THE BUILDING
USE AND PEOPLE GOT TRAPPED
INSIDE. THEY ALL DIED. AND THEN
THE CITY IS THE ONE WHO'S
GETTING SUED, SO IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ON THE HOOK FOR THIS
TYPE OF, CHANGE IN OCCUPANCY AND
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TYPES
AND ALL THAT, THEY ALSO NEED TO
BE ON THE FRONT END, AND WE
CAN'T JUST, LEAVE THEM OUT. AND
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S WHAT THESE
KIND OF BILLS ARE TRYING TO DO
IS LEAVE THEM OUT ON THE
SIDELINES, AND WE NEED THEM TO
WEIGH IN MORE, NOT LESS. SO I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF THAT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU TO YOUR
STAFF FOR SUPPORTING WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. YOU KNOW, ALL OF
THESE PROJECTS WILL STILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO MEET ALL
HEALTH, SAFETY AND BUILDING
CODES, MOST BUILDINGS WILL NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR CONVERSIONS, BUT
THOSE WHO WILL WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE FEASIBLE AND
GIVE A CLEAR, DEFINED,
PREDICTABLE PROCESS SO WE CAN
GET THIS DONE. WE CERTAINLY HAVE
A LOT OF CHALLENGES WITH A LOT
OF UNUSED BUILDINGS THAT THAT
THAT IS CREATING A LOT OF
PROBLEMS FOR OUR DOWNTOWNS. AND
THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP JUST ON
THE LABOR PIECE. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THE RECESS AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH FOLKS ON THAT AND FIND
THE RIGHT BALANCE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE STRONG LABOR
STANDARDS THAT CAN WORK ON THIS
BILL. SO YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE THE WORK ON THAT.
MADAM CHAIR. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. OKAY WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM
YET, SO WE CAN'T TAKE A MOTION,
BUT, WE WILL WHEN WE GET QUORUM.
AND I'LL LET YOU PRESENT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO'S BILL,
WHICH IS ITEM 13, AB 2910. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2910, WHICH DEALS WITH A
SIMILAR ISSUE. IT WILL ENABLE
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO ADOPT
ALTERNATIVE BUILDING REGULATIONS
TO FACILITATE THE CONVERSION OF
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS TO
RESIDENTIAL USES BEFORE THE CITY
MAY ADOPT ALTERNATIVE BUILDING
REGULATIONS, IT MUST SUBMIT ITS
PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION FOR REVIEW. THIS
COMMISSION MAY OFFER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OR REQUEST REVISIONS
TO THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS IN
ORDER TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH,
SAFETY AND WELFARE, AND THE
COMMISSION WILL ULTIMATELY
APPROVE OR DENY THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES A SUNSET PROVISION
ENSURING THAT ANY ALTERNATIVE
BUILDING STANDARDS ADOPTED BY
THE CITY SHALL ONLY REMAIN IN
EFFECT UNTIL THE STATE ADOPTS
ADAPTIVE USE BUILDING STANDARDS
PURSUANT TO AB FIVE, 29 OR
JANUARY 1ST, 2029, WHICHEVER
HAPPENS FIRST. THIS WOULD GIVE
LOS ANGELES THE FLEXIBILITY AND
NUANCE NEEDED TO AMEND ITS LOCAL
BUILDING CODE TO BETTER ENABLE
CONVERSION PROJECTS, WHILE
ENSURING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
STILL HAS THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF OVERSIGHT IN THE PROCESS. THE
AUTHOR HAS COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE RECESS TO
ENSURE THE BILL INCLUDES
APPROPRIATE MINIMUM SAFETY
STANDARDS. IT RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. LET'S, ESTABLISH QUORUM
. SENATOR SKINNER HERE. SKINNER,
PRESENT. ATROPOS. ATROPOS.
PRESENT. BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE.
SPEER. PRESENT. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. PRESENT.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR PRESENT.
PADILLA. CIERTO CIERTO. PRESENT.
UMBERG. WAHAB. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. ALL RIGHT. WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. LET ME
JUST SEE THE, MAIN WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. ANY MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. ANY
WITNESSES? YOU JUST WANT TO SAY
THEY ARE. GO AHEAD. LET'S MOVE
FAST. MADAM CHAIR STEVEN
STANZLER WITH BROWN STEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANKS
RAFA SONNENFELD WITH EMB ACTION,
WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED
POSITION, OVERALL, THE BILL IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IT EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE MORE CITIES, NOT JUST
THE CITY OF NOT JUST CITIES OVER
400,000, AND INCLUDE PROJECTS
THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL ZONING.
THANK YOU. SKYLAR WONACOTT,
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION BUILDING OWNERS
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHERS NOT SEEING ANY
OTHERS. IS THERE MAIN
OPPOSITION? DOES ANYONE WANT TO
COME TO THE MIC? PLEASE HURRY
UP. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
ANDREW MENDOZA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS OR
CALBO, IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION,
CARBO IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION OF CODE OFFICIALS
WORKING FOR LOCAL BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS AND INDUSTRY
PARTNERS. OUR MEMBERS ENSURE THE
UNIVERSAL APPLICATION OF THE
STATE BUILDING CODE IN ALL
JURISDICTIONS TO PROVIDE A
MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE PROVIDES THAT
LOCALITIES CAN AMEND THE STATE
BUILDING CODE AFTER PROVIDING
JUSTIFICATION FOR MORE
RESTRICTIVE STANDARDS. BUT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE NEVER TO REDUCE
THE MINIMUM LEVEL OF SAFETY
OFFERED. AB 2910 IS A PARTICULAR
CONCERN BECAUSE IT REORIENTS THE
FOCUS OF INSTITUTIONS FROM
ENSURING HEALTH AND SAFETY TO
INCREASING AFFORDABILITY. KALIBO
UNDERSTANDS THE CRISIS THAT WE
ARE FACING AND THE NEED TO
DEVELOP, BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION. SOME OF THE STANDARDS
OFFERED FOR THESE ADAPTIVE REUSE
PROJECTS INCLUDE REDUCING THE
SIZE OF ELEVATORS TO WEAR
GURNEYS WILL NOT FIT, LIMITING
THE CAPACITY OF SPRINKLER
SYSTEMS, AND THAT ELIMINATING
VESTIBULES AND STAIRWAYS. WHILE
THESE FEATURES MAY BE COST
PROHIBITIVE, THEY ARE DESIGN
CHOICES THAT CAN BE PRUDENT
DURING A FIRE BY RAISING THE
NEUTRAL PLANE OF SMOKE, REDUCING
THE HEAT IN A STACKED BUILDING
THAT AMPLIFIES PRESSURE, AND
EXPEDITING AN EMERGENCY EXIT.
CALBO BELIEVES THAT RESIDENTS
SHOULD BE OFFERED THE SAME
MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARD DESPITE
THEIR INCOME OR GEOGRAPHY, AND
THUS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB 2910. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION? ARE YOU
COMING UP TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? NO ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE. YOU WANT ME TO CALL ON YOU
IF YOU WANT. WELL, I'LL LET YOU
HAVE A DO MY BEST. I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE. IT'S GOING TO BE A
DIFFICULT QUESTION. THE PERSON
CAME UP TO OPPOSE THIS WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE UNIFORM
BUILDING CODE AND THE UNIFORM
FIRE CODE. THOSE ARE ALL ADOPTED
INTO CODE BY THE CITIES. CITIES
THEMSELVES. SO IF THEY HAVE A
FIRE DEPARTMENT, THEY ALL THEY
ALL USE THAT. SO ALL OF THAT HAS
TO GO IN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS AND THE ONE WE JUST HEARD
WAS THIS ONE, IS FOR THE CITY TO
DO THIS. SO THE CITY IS INVOLVED
IN THE WHOLE PROCESS, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE. AND SO THEY CAN
DETERMINE WHICH BUILDINGS ARE,
ARE ARE SUFFICIENT FOR THIS TYPE
OF USE OR REUSE AND WHICH ONES
AREN'T. IS THAT SOUND ABOUT
CORRECT? YES. AND THEY AND THEY
STILL HAVE TO SUBMIT IT TO THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
AND THERE'S A ROLE FOR THE STATE
IN APPROVING, THEY HAVE TO
SUBMIT THEIR PROPOSED
REGULATIONS TO THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
RIGHT. THE OTHER BILL, THOUGH,
DOESN'T STILL REQUIRES ALL
BUILDINGS TO COMPLY WITH THE
BUILDING CODES AND SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS. IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THOSE. RIGHT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES? ALL RIGHT, IS THERE
A MOTION? I'LL MOVE IT. GREAT.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEARS MOVED.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE.
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. THANK YOU. WE
WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL. MOTION IS
DUE PASS, AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE.
UMBERG. WAHAB. 6 TO 0. YOUR BILL
WILL BE ON CALL. AND, WE'LL
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAYNES OAN.
BILL. YES. THAT HE PRESENTED
RIGHT BEFORE THIS. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVED. OKAY, LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL ON THAT ONE. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED. AND THAT
BILL NUMBER, BECAUSE I DIDN'T,
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3068 BY
MEMBER HANEY. MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED. AND WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER, A SKINNER. AYE.
OCHOA BOGH. NO. A TROBOK. NO.
BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER I.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I. PADILLA
CIERTO. CIERTO. NO. UMBERG
WAHAB. 4 TO 2. ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL ALSO KEEP THAT ONE ON CALL.
AND, WE WILL NOW GO TO LET'S SEE
WHO'S IN THE ROOM, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, I THINK YOU
ARE. NEXT, YOU HAVE BILLS, ITEMS
NUMBER ONE. AND TWO. AS YOU COME
UP TO BE GET READY FOR PRESENT.
LET ME LET JUST TELL THE MEMBERS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ARE.
ITEM FOUR AB 1817, ITEM SEVEN,
AB 2117. ITEM 11 AB 2550. ITEM
14 AB 3012. ITEM 15 AB 3057 AND
THAT'S IT. CAN I HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR? ALL
RIGHT, SO WE'VE GOT THE MOTION
FROM, I BELIEVE IT WAS CORTEZ.
OH, SORRY. SATO. SENATOR SATO,
WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL ON THAT,
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM, MISS
FRIEDMAN. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, SENATOR SKINNER, A
SKINNER. AYE. OKOBO A TROBOK.
AYE. BREAKSPEAR BREAKSPEAR. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. SATO SERRATO. AYE.
UMBERG. WAHAB. 6 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL KEEP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL. WE'LL NOW HEAR
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
ITEM ONE, AB 930. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
LIKE TO BOOST INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER,
THEY LACK ACCESS TO FUNDING.
PROJECTS ARE NOT ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE DUE TO A LACK OF
AVAILABLE LAND, HIGH
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS, WEAK
MARKET COMPS, AND EXPECT
EXPENSIVE AND RISKY ENTITLEMENT
PROCESSES. IN 1945, CALIFORNIA
ENACTED THE COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT ACT TO ASSIST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN ELIMINATING
BLIGHT THROUGH REDEVELOPMENT.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWED
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES TO USE
STATE AND LOCAL INCREMENTAL
PROPERTY TAX TO SUPPORT
REDEVELOPMENT. THIS PROGRAM WAS
USED BY MANY COMMUNITIES VERY
SUCCESSFULLY, INCLUDING MY OWN,
IN GLENDALE, TO ELIMINATE BLIGHT
AND RESULTED IN THOUSANDS OF NEW
HOUSING UNITS OVER THE COURSE OF
ITS 67 YEAR HISTORY. IN
FEBRUARY. IN 2012, REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WERE DISSOLVED AND MANY
MUNICIPALITIES, INCLUDING MINE,
LOST THE BULK OF THEIR FUNDING
TO CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB
930 WERE PERMITTED TWO OR MORE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO JOINTLY
FORM A REINVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A SUSTAINABLE
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA, WHICH
HAPPENS TO COME TO RISE IF YOU
SPELL IT OUT, A DISTRICT TO
UNLOCK TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND EQUITABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND LOCATION
EFFICIENT AREAS RISE DISTRICT
PLANS WILL ALIGN WITH
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS, SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES. THESE
PLANS WILL ALIGN INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
EXISTING COMMUNITY CENTERS,
WHILE REDUCING CAR DEPENDANCE,
LOWERING CARBON EMISSIONS, AND
ENCOURAGING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND CLIMATE RESILIENT HOUSING
PRODUCTION. NEAR TRANSIT AND
WALKABLE COMMUNITIES. AB 930 THE
RISE ACT WILL ALIGN PLANNING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
REFOCUS GROWTH TOWARDS COMMUNITY
CENTERS. THE BILL IS SPONSORED.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS, SPUR
AND CIVIC WELL AND IS SUPPORTED
BY CALIFORNIA HOME BUILDING
ALLIANCE, THE CITY OF OAKLAND,
MONTEREY COUNTY, AND SCAG IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE MIA KING,
SENIOR VP WITH RELATED
CALIFORNIA AND DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNCIL, INFILL BUILDER. AND
ROGER DICKINSON IS ROGER. HI,
ROGER. DIRECTOR, POLICY DIRECTOR
FROM CIVIC. WELL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. GO AHEAD, GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I AM
MIA KONG. I'M AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER. I'VE BEEN
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
THE LAST 25 YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A FOUNDING BOARD MEMBER
OF THE COUNCIL OF INFILL
BUILDERS. ONE OF THE BILL'S VERY
PROUD CO-SPONSORS. AB 930,
INCENTIVIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO WORK TOGETHER. EVERYONE HAS A
SEAT AT THE TABLE TO PLAN AND
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN EXISTING
COMMUNITIES. NEAR TRANSIT RISE
UNLOCKS TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
TO UPGRADE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
MAKE COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT,
AND TO PAVE THE WAY FOR MORE
INFILL HOUSING IN EXISTING
COMMUNITIES WHERE RESIDENTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO WALK, BIKE OR
TAKE PUBLIC TRANSIT TO GET.
AROUND 50% OF THE MONEY IS
REQUIRED TO BE SPENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS AND
30% FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB
930 ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK TO
REDUCE VMT CONSISTENT WITH
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
AND ESTABLISHES A VIRTUOUS CYCLE
WITH DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AB 930
ESTABLISHES THE RISE REVOLVING
LOAN FUND WITH IBANK. UPON
APPROPRIATIONS, IBANK WILL
PROVIDE LOW COST LOANS TO ALL
RISE DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M ROGER
DICKINSON. THE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR CIVIC. WELL, PREVIOUSLY, THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL. I'VE BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN EFFORTS TO INTEGRATE
LAND USE AND TRANSPORTATION FOR
MULTIPLE DECADES. AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR, AS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY, AND AS A CITIZEN TO
PROMOTE A STRONGER ECONOMY, A
HEALTHIER ENVIRONMENT AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING AS A PRINCIPAL
COAUTHOR OF SB 628 BY SENATOR
BELL THAT AUTHORIZED THE
CREATION OF ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS, OR IFDS. AB 930
BUILDS ON THE CONCEPT OF IFDS BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEDICATE GROWTH IN LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE TO FINANCE
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS NEAR TRANSIT,
AND SO DOING. AB 930 PROVIDES A
FORM OF VALUE CAPTURE PROPERTIES
THAT ENJOY ENHANCED VALUE DUE TO
THEIR PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT WILL
HELP UNDERWRITE THE COST OF
PUBLIC INVESTMENT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
FOCUS THAT PUBLIC INVESTMENT
WHERE IT WILL YIELD THE GREATEST
RETURN IN FOSTERING THE ELEMENTS
ON WHICH SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
DEPEND. A GREATER SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A DEVELOPMENT
PATTERN THAT REDUCES TRIPS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. A
SETTING THAT PROVIDES
WALKABILITY AND SOCIAL COHESION.
AB 930 CAN JUMP START PROJECTS
THAT WILL BRING THESE RESULTS
THROUGH A CONCEPT OF A STATE
REVOLVING LOAN PROGRAM AND
DOVETAIL WITH AB 2011 AND SB SIX
FROM 2022 TO ACCELERATE THE
REBIRTH OF NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL PROVIDES A
SIGNIFICANT NEW TOOL FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO USE AS THEY
ENDEAVOR TO GROW SMARTER. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR EYES
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB 930. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ADD ON. MEET ME TWOS.
HOLLY FIRMANDO DEJESUS WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF
THE BILL, SPUR, CHARLES WATSON,
ON BEHALF OF BART, THE BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BOB NAYLOR
FOR FIELDSTEAD AND COMPANY IN
SUPPORT. MARY ELLEN SHEA,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES. MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT. KEVIN GILHOOLY
FROM THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS IN
SUPPORT. REBECCA MARQUEZ,
REPRESENTING LEADINGAGE
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. RALPH
SONNENFELD, ON BEHALF OF EMB
ACTION AND OUR NEARLY TWO DOZEN
CHAPTERS IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S REGISTERED OPPOSITION.
OKAY. SEEING NONE, ANYBODY WANT
TO COME TO THE MIC TO ADD
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET'S
GO TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY GO
AHEAD. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU. THIS IS A REALLY
AMBITIOUS BILL. THAT'S EXCITING.
I WAS PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
HAVING EYE BANK PROVIDE SEED
MONEY. I THINK THAT'S AN
INNOVATIVE IDEA. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO COMMEND YOU ON THIS
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WHO WHO SPOKE YOUR
SUPPORTERS TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'VE GOT
A MOTION, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS NOW FOR TWO YEARS, AND
THERE'S A LOT OF NEED FOR THIS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. SO I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. GREAT.
LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL. I
THOUGHT YOU HAD MOVED. YEAH
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR SKINNER,
A SKINNER. AYE. Ã CHIRLA BOEG A
TROBERG. NO. BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER I CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE MENGIBAR.
PADILLA. CIERTO UMBERG. WAHAB. 3
TO 1. GREAT. WE'LL. IT'S STILL
ON CALL, WE NEED OBVIOUSLY
MEMBERS, SO WE'LL GO TO YOUR
NEXT ITEM. ITEM 2AB2553. THANK
YOU. AB 2553 CLARIFIES WHEN
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MUST IMPOSE
LOWER TRAFFIC IMPACT FEES ON
TRANSIT, PROXIMATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. IT ALSO UPDATES
THE DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP TO REFLECT POST-COVID
SERVICE LEVELS. FIRST, IF A
LOCAL AGENCY HAS ADOPTED A
TRAFFIC IMPACT FEE, THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT REQUIRES THE
FEE TO BE SET AT A LOWER RATE
FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
THAT GENERATE REDUCED VEHICLE
TRIPS, AS DETERMINED BY WHETHER
THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MEETS
SEVERAL CRITERIA, INCLUDING
PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT. CURRENTLY
THE LAW REQUIRES THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BE WITHIN ONE HALF
MILE OF A TRANSIT STATION, WHICH
IS A NARROW DEFINITION THAT
EXCLUDES MANY PROJECTS WELL
SERVED BY TRANSIT. MANY LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE VERY HIGH TRAFFIC
IMPACT FEES, POSING AN
IMPEDIMENT TO THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING AND OVERCHARGING.
TRANSIT. PROXIMATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WOULD HAVE
MINIMAL TRAFFIC IMPACTS.
HOWEVER, SEVERAL OTHER STATUTES,
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT AND
THE STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW,
ENCOURAGED DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
TO OCCUR. PROXIMATE TO TRANSIT
BY PROVIDING BENEFITS SUCH AS
STREAMLINED ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS AND LOWER PARKING
STANDARDS, AMONG OTHERS. UNDER
THESE STATUTES, A DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT MUST BE PROXIMATE TO A
MAJOR TRANSIT STOP, WHICH, AMONG
OTHER THINGS, INCLUDE THE
INTERSECTION OF TWO OR MORE
MAJOR BUS ROUTES WITH A
FREQUENCY OF 15 MINUTES OR LESS
DURING MORNING OR AFTERNOON PEAK
COMMUTE TIMES. AB 2553 REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO CONSIDER
REDUCING TRAFFIC IMPACT FEES FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN ONE
HALF MILE OF MAJOR TRANSIT
STOPS, WHICH WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DEVELOPMENTS THAT
QUALIFY FOR THE REDUCTION
COMPARED TO THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENT TO BE PROXIMATE TO A
TRANSIT STATION. A SECOND, THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC CAUSED A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP AND MANY OF OUR
AGENCIES ARE RECOVERING FROM
THAT. BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOESN'T IMPACT OUR
ABILITY TO BUILD HOUSING. SO WE,
YOU KNOW, AND EVEN IF WITH LOWER
FREQUENCY, WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE
RIDING TRANSIT WHO ARE MOVING
INTO UNITS THAT ARE CLOSE TO THE
TRANSIT, THAT THEY RELY ON TO
ADDRESS THIS CONCERN. AB 2553
AMENDS THE DEFINITION OF MAJOR
TRANSIT STOP TO INCREASE THE
HEADWAYS FOR BUS ROUTES FROM 15
MINUTES TO 20 MINUTES,
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS HOLLY
PHªN MUNI DÍAS ON BEHALF OF
SPUR. THE BILL HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION, AND I REQUEST,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST, AN AYE
VOTE. KHN HOLLY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF SPUR. AND THERE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION, A PROUD
SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER OF MANY
LOCAL AND STATE INITIATIVES THAT
ARE TRYING TO FACILITATE MORE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING, NEAR
TRANSIT AND JUST TO REITERATE
WHAT THE MEMBER WAS SAYING, THIS
IS NOT A MANDATE. IT'S JUST
REQUIRING THE CITIES THAT THEY
MUST CONSIDER A REDUCTION IN
FEES. IT DOESN'T GUARANTEE THAT
THE FEES ARE GOING TO BE
REDUCED. THEY JUST MUST CONSIDER
THEM IN THE SAME WAY THAT THEY
DO A HOUSING PROJECT NEAR A
STATION, AS NEAR A STOP. SO WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT? COME TO ADD YOUR ME.
TO. MCKINLEY THOMPSON. MORLEY,
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROFESSIONALS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. REBECCA
MARCUS, REPRESENTING LEADINGAGE
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. KEITH
COOLIDGE, ON BEHALF OF AARP
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH MP ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BROOKE
PRITCHARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT FOR
ME AGAIN ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY, CALIFORNIA
SANDHILL PROPERTIES AND ALSO
CIVIC WELL IN SUPPORT. GREAT ALL
RIGHT. OPPOSITION WE HAVE NONE
REGISTERED. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO COME TO
THE MIC EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, LET'S GO TO
THE DÍAS. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
ALL RIGHT, WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL.
I'LL ASK HER TO CLOSE. OH
APOLOGIES. YOU MAY CLOSE. I'LL
ACCEPT THE MOTION AS MY CLOSE.
OKAY GREAT. EXCELLENT MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE FLOOR, SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER I OTRO BOGUE
MUCHO BOGUE. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR.
PADILLA SERRATO. UMBERG. WAHAB.
4 TO 0. EXCELLENT. ALL RIGHT. SO
SIMILARLY, MEMBER. WE'LL GO TO
YOUR THIRD ITEM, AB 2712, WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU,
MEMBERS AB 2712 IS A DISTRICT
BILL. THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FROM
ALLOWING RESIDENTS AND VISITORS
OF CERTAIN DEVELOPMENTS FROM
GETTING PERMITS TO PARK IN A
PREFERENTIAL PARKING AREA. IF
THE NEW DEVELOPMENT IS LOCATED
IN A PREFERENTIAL PARKING AREA
AND NOT SUBJECT TO MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS, YOU MAY
REMEMBER THAT LAST YEAR I
COAUTHORED A BILL ALONG WITH
SENATOR PORTANTINO TO PROHIBIT
THE USE OF MINIMUM PARKING
STANDARDS IN DIRECT PROXIMITY TO
TRANSIT. WHAT WE DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE AT THAT POINT IS THAT
THERE WOULD BE DEVELOPERS WHO
WOULD BUILD MARKET RATE HOUSING,
AND OFFER TO THEIR RESIDENTS
PREFERENTIAL PARKING PASSES FOR
THE NEIGHBORHOODS BEHIND THESE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS, MANY OF WHICH
ARE ON COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS,
THAT WHEN THE PREFERENTIAL
PARKING PASSES WERE FIRST
ESTABLISHED FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS, DIDN'T EVEN ALLOW
APARTMENTS ON THOSE CORRIDORS.
BUT WE HAVE DONE STATE LAWS THAT
NOW ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO BUILD
HOUSING, EVEN ON COMMERCIAL
CORRIDORS THAT HAVE OPENED UP
AND AMBIGUITY IN MANY PLACES IN
LOS ANGELES AS TO WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING
PREFERENTIAL PARKING PASSES FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE ALREADY
EXTREMELY PARKING BURDENED. IN
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS, CURB
PARKING IS AT A PREMIUM BECAUSE
OF OLDER DEVELOPMENT THAT THAT
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF
PARKING FOR THOSE RESIDENTS.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
RIGHT NOW IS DEVELOPMENT IN
THESE COMMUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE WHO ARE WANTING TO USE
TRANSIT AND ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO
GET AROUND. WHAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE IS MORE AND MORE CARS
COMING INTO ALREADY OVER
CONGESTED URBAN AREAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF CITIES WHERE WE KNOW
WE HAVE A PARKING PROBLEM, WE
EXPECT DEVELOPERS TO ADD THE
PARKING THAT THEY NEED FOR THEIR
LOCATIONS. BUT WE WHAT WE WANT
IN AREAS WHERE WE ALREADY HAVE A
LOT OF CONGESTION IS ACTUALLY
PEOPLE TO BE USING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND THE WHOLE
POINT OF MY BILL LAST YEAR ABOUT
PARKING WAS TO ALLOW THE
BUILDING OF UNITS WITHOUT
PARKING FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE CARS. AND THERE ARE MANY OF
THEM IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE
WILLING TO RENT AN APARTMENT FOR
LESS MONEY THAN A MARKET RATE
UNIT WOULD COST BECAUSE THEY ARE
TAKING UBERS, THEY ARE USING THE
BUS, THEY ARE USING OTHER KINDS
OF PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OR
RIDING THEIR BIKES BY GIVING
THOSE RESIDENTS IN THESE
BUILDINGS, SOMETIMES SOME OF
THEM VERY LARGE BUILDINGS,
PARKING PASSES TO PARK IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE WE KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE CURB SPACE. WE ARE
SETTING THE STAGE FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS TO OPPOSE NEW HOUSING,
WHEREAS THEY OTHERWISE WOULD
REALIZE THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAVE SUCH A HUGE IMPACT ON THEM
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
PARKING AND THE LACK OF ABILITY
TO ACCOMMODATE A LOT OF NEW
AUTOMOBILES. SO THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL. IT'S TRYING TO
DEAL WITH A PROBLEM THAT WE
DIDN'T ANTICIPATE BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THESE VERY
LARGE BUILDINGS ARE GOING TO BE
PUT UP IN AREAS WITH RESTRICTED
PARKING, AND THAT THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO
INTERPRET OUR LAW AND WOULD AIR
ON THE SIDE OF GIVING HUNDREDS
OF NEW RESIDENTS PREFERENTIAL
PARKING PASSES. THE BILL HAS
RESTRICTIONS PUT ON BY THE
FORMER COMMITTEE THAT IT WENT
THROUGH IN THE ASSEMBLY TO LIMIT
THIS, TO EXCLUDE LOW INCOME
HOUSING AND ALSO SMALLER UNITS.
SO THAT IF SOMEONE'S ADDING A
FEW UNITS TO AN EXISTING
BUILDING, FOR INSTANCE, THEY CAN
STILL GET A PARKING PERMIT FOR
THOSE RESIDENTS, BUT NOT FOR
LARGER DEVELOPMENTS, SO AGAIN,
THIS THIS EXEMPTS RESIDENTS IN
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE 20 UNITS
OR LESS. IT EXEMPTS RESIDENTS IN
UNITS THAT ARE DEED RESTRICTED,
INTENDED FOR HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
LOW INCOME, EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
OR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND
IT ALSO ALLOWS THE CITY TO ISSUE
PERMITS IF THEY FEEL THAT IF
THEY DO A PUBLIC PROCESS AND
DETERMINE THAT GIVING THOSE
PERMITS IS NOT GOING TO BE
DETRIMENTAL TO EXISTING
RESIDENTS. AND I'M WE WERE
ENVISIONING IN THIS CASE,
SITUATIONS LIKE I HAVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, WHERE THE ONLY
REASON WE HAVE PREFERENTIAL
PARKING ON MY STREET IS BECAUSE
A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE EVERY DAY
THE PARENTS WOULD PARK ALL OVER
THE NEIGHBORHOOD FOR ONE HALF
HOUR IF THERE WASN'T A PERMIT
PARKING DISTRICT. BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT. BUT NEW RESIDENTS CAN BE
PERFECTLY ACCOMMODATED IN THAT
DISTRICT, SO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THE CITY'S HAD SOME
FLEXIBILITY. BUT THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT'S
TRANSPARENT AND WHERE THE
RESIDENTS COULD WEIGH IN AND
WITH THAT, I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS DISTRICT BILL. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY. OH, YES.
WE DO. SPEAKING ON IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2712 TODAY IS NATALIE BROWN
WITH THE PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE. AND THIS
BILL, BY THE WAY, HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR SKINNER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE, AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SECOND WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS SAID AND TO EXPRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEED FOR THE SMART
AND RESPONSIBLE PARKING REFORMS
PUT FORTH IN AB 2712. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO SUPPORT
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT
ENCROACHING ON AND OVERCROWDING
THE CURB PARKING THAT EXISTING
RESIDENTS RELY ON. BY EXCLUDING
LARGE AND LOW AND NO PARKING
DEVELOPMENT FROM PREFERENTIAL
PARKING DISTRICTS IN LOS
ANGELES. AB 2712 WILL ONE
PREVENT INFILL DEVELOPMENT FROM
DISPLACING NEIGHBORS FROM THE
CURB PARKING THEY CURRENTLY RELY
ON, THEREBY PRESERVING EXISTING
PARKING SUPPLY. TWO IT WILL
DIFFUSE OPPOSITION TO NEW
HOUSING AND BUSINESSES ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THEY WILL OVERCROWD
NEARBY STREET PARKING, MAKING IT
EASIER TO GET NEEDED HOUSING OFF
THE GROUND AND THREE, IT WILL
ENSURE THAT TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT IS ACTUALLY TRANSIT
ORIENTED. THESE PROJECTS WOULD
SUPPORT SHOULD SUPPORT CAR FREE
TENANTS AND CUSTOMERS, NOT
SIMPLY PUSH PARKING DEMANDS TO
ALREADY CROWDED STREETS. AB 2712
IS A WIN FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR EXISTING NEIGHBORS, AND FOR
OUR CLIMATE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
GOALS. WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
CANNOT MEET ITS LONG TERM
CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT REFORMING
OUR LAND USE PATTERNS TO CURB
VMT GROWTH. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WON'T TRULY
BE AFFORDABLE AS LONG AS LOW
WAGE HOUSEHOLDS ARE DISPLACED
THE URBAN PERIPHERY AND PRICED
OUT OF TRANSIT ACCESS AND ACCESS
TO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. WHERE
TRANSIT IS AN OPTION, WE KNOW
THAT MANDATORY PARKING MINIMUMS
IMPOSE ARTIFICIALLY INFLATED
PRICES ON RESIDENTS THAT THEY DO
NOT NEED, AND POTENTIALLY CANNOT
AFFORD. BY ADDRESSING CONCERNS
ABOUT REMOVING PARKING MINIMUMS
AND REDUCING OPPOSITION TO
NEARBY LOW INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, THIS BILL FOSTERS
INCLUSIVE AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND BY CURBING URBAN
SPRAWL AND INDUCED CAR USAGE,
THIS BILL CONTRIBUTES TO
REDUCTIONS IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED, THEREBY REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION, MITIGATING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS, AND ADVANCING
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS, WHICH IS A WIN FOR
EVERYONE. AB 2712 IS AN
INCREDIBLY CREATIVE AND
INCREDIBLY PRAGMATIC APPROACH TO
OUR CLIMATE AND HOUSING CRISES
THAT SUPPORTS BOTH EQUITY AND
EXISTING COMMUNITY NEEDS. THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT AND
THOUGHTFUL, AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
NOW, ANY OPPOSITION? REGISTERED
OPPOSITION OKAY. HELLO. SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS BARBARA GALLON. I LEAD
THE FRIENDS OF HISTORIC MIRACLE
MILE IN LOS ANGELES, AND I STAND
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF AT LEAST
TEN OTHER NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
MULTIFAMILY APARTMENT DISTRICTS
IN LOS ANGELES, BECAUSE WE SHARE
CONCERNS ABOUT REMAINING
LOOPHOLES IN AB 2712, THE CORE
PURPOSE WE NOT ONLY SUPPORT, WE
ACTUALLY BROUGHT THAT BILL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, TO
WHOM WE'RE SO GRATEFUL THAT SHE
TOOK IT UP. THE LOOPHOLES HAVE
TO DO WITH THE EXCEPTION FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF 20 UNITS OR LESS,
THE EXCEPTION FOR DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS. AND WE WERE
UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HAD
STRUCK THE EXCEPTION FOR A CITY
TO SUBJECTIVELY DETERMINE, WITH
NO METRICS, OVERCROWDING. SO WE
WERE NOT PREPARED BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE TOLD THAT
WAS TAKEN OUT. IS THAT STILL IN
THE BILL? THE SUBJECTIVE
DETERMINATION, THE WAY IT WAS
WORDED, IF IT WASN'T TAKEN OUT,
IS SORRY THAT WAS TAKEN OUT.
THAT WAS A OH, THANK GOODNESS
THAT IS NO LONGER IN THE BILL.
JIM, WE HAVE A IT WAS JUST A
MISTAKE TO LEAVE THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH BECAUSE THAT WAS A BIG
ONE. YEAH OUR, OUR ASSOCIATIONS
AND ALL OF YOU, IF YOU'VE SEEN
THE LETTERS FROM IN THE PORTAL,
I REALLY DO SPEAK WITH
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS THAT
REPRESENT LITERALLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF RENTERS IN HISTORIC
20S, 30S, 40S BUILDINGS. WE DO
NOT HAVE NEARLY ENOUGH CURB
PARKING. THERE'S FAR MORE
PERMITS THAT ALREADY EXIST. SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THOSE EXCEPTIONS
IN LÀ DOT POLICY IS YOU CAN GET
UP TO FIVE PERMITS PER
RESIDENCE. SO A 20 UNIT
BUILDING. AND BY THE WAY, ALL
LUXURY BECAUSE AB 2097 HAS NO
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT, A 20
UNIT DEVELOPMENT, THOSE
RESIDENTS CAN OBTAIN 100 PERMITS
TO PARK 100 CARS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT'S TO POLLUTE
OUR AIR. WE ONLY HAVE 70 CURB
SPACES PER BLOCK. A DEED
RESTRICTED COMPONENT OF A
LUXURIOUS 358 STORY, 42 STORY
LUXURY HIGH RISE WITH 29
AFFORDABLE UNITS. THOSE 29
AFFORDABLE UNITS CAN OBTAIN 145
PERMITS TO PARK 145 CARS, AND
THEY'RE TAKING SPACES FROM LOW
INCOME. WE'RE ALREADY THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS
LIVING IN 1920S AND 30S
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE ONE OUTLET
PER WALL, THAT DON'T HAVE ANY
AMENITIES, NO DISHWASHERS.
THEY'RE OLD BUILDINGS, THEY'RE
CHARMING, BUT THEY ALSO ARE NOT
CONTEMPORARY AMENITIES. AND WE
LIVE IN THEM BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
LEAVE OUR RENT STAYS PREDICTABLE
FOR DECADES BECAUSE OLDER
HOUSING IS CHEAPER THAN NEWER
HOUSING, AND THAT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED. SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WANTING TO
LOOK OUT FOR PEOPLE IN LOWER
INCOME HOUSING, BUT THAT'S US.
THOUSANDS OF US IN A GIVEN
APARTMENT, SOMEONE PAYING $950.
THE APARTMENT NEXT TO THEM
VACATED BECAUSE SOMEBODY CAN'T
DEAL WITH THEIRS. NOW, ANOTHER
THOUSAND PEOPLE GETTING PERMITS
IN A DISTRICT THAT DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOR US. THEY MOVE OUT.
THEIR APARTMENT WILL BE RE
RENTED FOR IF YOU WANT TO GIVE
ANY TIME TO THE OTHER. SPEAKER
2900 BECAUSE MULTIPLY BY FIVE
OUT OF TIME. SORRY. OKAY PLEASE
REMOVE THESE LOOPHOLES. AND THEN
WE LOVE THAT BILL. WE WROTE THE
BILL. PLEASE REMOVE THOSE
LOOPHOLES. MY NAME IS BEN
HARDING. I LEAD MIRACLE MILE
ACTION IN LOS ANGELES. AND THEN
THEY OPPOSES THESE TWO LOOPHOLES
IN AB 2712. BUT WE'D STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL IF THE
LOOPHOLES ARE REMOVED.
SPECIFICALLY, WE WANT TO REMOVE
THE EXCEPTION FOR DEVELOPMENTS
OF 20 OR FEWER UNITS AND THE
EXCEPTION FOR OCCUPANTS OF DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS. IT'S
SELF-DEFEATING TO PRESENT
BUILDINGS AS TRANSIT ORIENTED,
THEN TURN AROUND AND ISSUE
PARKING PERMITS FOR THESE
RESIDENTS. GRANTING PARKING
PRIVILEGES ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
BRING CARS, SOMETHING AB 2097
WAS INTENDED TO PREVENT. WE WANT
THE COMMITTEE TO REALIZE THAT IN
LA, BUILDING A NEW DEVELOPMENT
WITHOUT PARKING DOESN'T CAUSE
PEOPLE TO GIVE UP CARS IF THEY
CAN UTILIZE STREET PARKING. FOR
19 YEARS, I'VE LIVED IN A 19
2932 UNIT BUILDING WITH NO
PARKING. NEIGHBORS AND I ALL
HAVE CARS. WE ALL FIGHT FOR
STREET PARKING. THERE ARE MORE
PERMITS ALREADY ISSUED THAN
AVAILABLE SPACES. IF I CAN'T
FIND A SPOT IN MY DISTRICT, I
HAVE TO PARK PERHAPS SIX BLOCKS
AWAY. WALK HOME IN THE DARK. WE
PUT UP WITH THIS BECAUSE RENT IN
OLDER BUILDINGS IS AFFORDABLE.
IF WE STAY PUT UNDER RENT
STABILIZATION. EVERY PERMIT
ISSUED TO RESIDENTS OF NEW
DEVELOPMENTS TAKES AWAY ALREADY
SCARCE PARKING FROM SOMEONE LIKE
ME AND MY NEIGHBORS. WE WILL
HAVE TO MOVE AND FACE MARKET
RATE RENT, WHICH WE CAN'T
AFFORD. THE RENT FOR MY UNIT
WOULD BE RAISED THEN FOR THE
NEXT PERSON WHO TAKES MY VACATED
APARTMENT. THE RESULT IS A LOSS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. WE CAN PREVENT
THAT BY REMOVING THESE
LOOPHOLES. NEW DEVELOPMENTS, SO
THAT NEW DEVELOPMENTS CAN'T
FLOOD OUR NEIGHBORHOOD WITH
CARS. OTHERWISE, AB 2712 IS JUST
LIKE A BUCKET PLACED UNDER A
ROOF LEAK WITH NO PLAN TO REPAIR
THE ROOF. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION?
OKAY LET'S, MISS, SENATOR CORTEZ
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL, THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT, HER VALIANT
EFFORTS. YOU KNOW, TO DEAL WITH
THIS ISSUE AND TO PROMOTE THE
RIGHT THINGS, WHICH I AGREE, IN
TERMS OF THE OUTCOMES. AND I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL, WE TALKED LAST YEAR ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
INTEGRATED, BOTH IN TERMS OF
DEMOGRAPHICS AND JUST IN TERMS
OF LAND USE. IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
THAT OFTEN THAT YOU SEE THOSE IN
IN SUBURBAN AND URBAN AREAS
ANYMORE, WITH A FEW PLACES IN
THE BAY AREA, YOU KNOW, CLEARLY,
SAN FRANCISCO, PARTS OF EAST SAN
JOSE, WHERE YOU'LL HAVE SINGLE
FAMILY UP AGAINST MULTIFAMILY,
UP AGAINST COMMERCIAL, ALL SIDE
BY SIDE AND THEN WHEN YOU GET
INTO THE PROMOTING TRANSIT AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES, IT
BECOMES A LITTLE MORE TRICKY IN
TERMS OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. BUT I'M ACTUALLY
REALLY HAPPY TO SEE YOU BRINGING
BACK THIS BILL. ALBEIT ON A
DISTRICT WIDE BASIS, YOU KNOW,
TO COME IN AND FOCUS ON, OKAY,
YOU KNOW, IF THERE'S THINGS THAT
AREN'T WORKING EXACTLY RIGHT,
LET'S COME BACK WITH A BILL AND
DEAL WITH THAT. AND I THINK THIS
WHOLE AREA IS GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING, EVOLVING BODY OF WORK
LIKE THAT. AND I KNOW, OTHERS
WILL TAKE THAT UP, IN YEARS TO
COME. AND TO THE OPPOSITION, I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND ALL OF WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING AND ARE
FRUSTRATED ABOUT, BUT AGAIN, WE
NEED TO KEEP HEARING FROM FOLKS
LIKE THE OPPOSITIONS TO, YOU
KNOW, TO BETTER THESE POLICIES
IN THE FUTURE. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET THERE IN ONE BILL OR TWO
BILLS. IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE
ITERATIVE THINGS IN LEGISLATION,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADVANCE LEGISLATION LIKE WAS
DONE LAST YEAR ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS. YOU'RE GOING TO RUN INTO
THESE MORE NUANCED ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE CORRECTED LATER ON.
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR COMING BACK
AND SAYING, OKAY, YOU KNOW, A
LITTLE COURSE CORRECTION NEEDS
TO BE DONE HERE. SOME MORE WILL
BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE. I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S GOING
TO BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE,
PERHAPS, IS YOU KNOW, IS AS MUCH
AS, YOU KNOW, A PROPERTY RIGHTS
PERSON AS I TEND TO BE BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND, THE MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTY OWNERS AND MANAGERS
NEED TO BE REALLY, REALLY CLEAR
WITH PEOPLE AS TO WHAT THE
SITUATION IS. YOU KNOW, I HAD
ACTUALLY DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, MY YOUNGEST OF FOUR
CHILDREN MOVE INTO AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX, AND BEING THE LAWYER I
AM, I LOOKED OVER THE LEASE FOR
HIM AND I SAID, HEY, YOU KNOW,
IT SAYS PARKING IS AVAILABLE. IT
DOESN'T SAY ASSIGNED. HE SAID,
WELL, THEY TOLD ME, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE CARPORTS AND I WENT
THERE. I LOOKED THEY HAVE
CARPORTS. I SAID, YEAH, BUT THE
LEGAL LANGUAGE SAYS PARKING IS
AVAILABLE. IT DOESN'T SAY THAT
THEY'VE ASSIGNED ANYTHING TO
YOU. AND HE SAID, YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT. WELL, WHAT
IT DID IS IT THERE WASN'T A
CARPORT FOR HIM AND IT PUSHED
HIM. YOU KNOW, INTO THE ADJACENT
RESIDENTIAL AREA, WHICH IS OKAY
DURING CERTAIN TIMES OF THE DAY
AND OTHER TIMES OF THE DAY, IT'S
BAD FOR EVERYBODY BECAUSE
WHATEVER, EVERYBODY'S COMING
HOME AT THE SAME TIME. FOR
EXAMPLE, THOSE THOSE KINDS OF
DISCLOSURES I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND PROBABLY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AS WE AS WE ADOPT
THESE POLICIES TO TRY TO ADVANCE
, AND ENCOURAGE, YOU KNOW,
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. I THINK
THERE'S SOME SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE DISCLOSING TO ALL
CONCERNED. AND THEN ECONOMICS
WILL START TO TAKE OVER A LITTLE
BIT. AND PEOPLE'S DECISION
MAKING WILL WILL HAVE AN
INFLUENCE ON, YOU KNOW, ON ALL
OF THIS. BUT AGAIN, I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTIVE. I COMMEND THE
AUTHOR, AND I WOULD JUST ASK THE
OPPOSITION, FOR WHATEVER IT'S
WORTH, FROM A GUY HERE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE TO BE
PERSISTENT, BUT BE PATIENT
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO TAKE,
MAYBE ANOTHER YEAR OR TWO TO GET
THIS EXACTLY RIGHT IN MY OPINION
. SENATOR YES. THANK YOU, SO I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THE OPPOSITION,
WELL, IT WAS POINTED OUT ALSO IN
THE STAFF REPORT ABOUT THE
DECISION ABOUT 20 UNITS. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS A
DISCUSSION WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF BEFOREHAND, BUT WAS 20
UNITS HAVING AN EXEMPTION? SEEMS
LIKE IT'S LARGER THAN A MOM AND
POP. WHO WOULD BE ADDING
SOMETHING 1 OR 2 UNITS. SO I
JUST WAS CURIOUS ABOUT THAT
NUMBER, BECAUSE IT SEEMS SORT OF
HIGH TO HAVE A CARVE OUT THAT'S
THAT BIG. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR,
LIKE MANY THINGS, AND FIRST I
WANT TO THANK I DON'T WANT TO
CALL THEM THE OPPONENTS BECAUSE
THEY'VE ACTUALLY BEEN OUR
PARTNERS IN THIS LEGISLATION FOR
COMING UP AND FOR CARING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND BEING PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT, THEY'VE THEY'RE GREAT
PARTNERS. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
HERE FOR EIGHT YEARS. AND THE
WAY THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
ALWAYS WORKS IS WE INTRODUCE THE
PERFECT BILL THAT WE WANT TO
INTRODUCE, AND THEN WE GO IN
FRONT OF A COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOMETIMES HAVE
TO HAVE OFTEN HAVE OTHER IDEAS.
AND THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS HAVE
OTHER IDEAS. AND WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE ASSEMBLY WAS WE
INTRODUCED A BILL WITHOUT WHAT
THEY ARE CALLING LOOPHOLES. WE
INTRODUCED A BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE WAS A NO RECO ON THE
BILL. THEY DID NOT LIKE THE
BILL. THEY THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
UNFAIR FOR THE NEW RESIDENTS,
NOT TO HAVE THE EXACT SAME
PRIVILEGE AS THE EXISTING
RESIDENTS IN TERMS OF
PREFERENTIAL PARKING PASSES, AND
THEY WERE NÓ RECO, AND WE DID
NOT GET THE BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE. WE GOT
RECONSIDERATION. WE SAT DOWN
WITH THE COMMITTEE, CHAIR IN
LOCAL GOV. AND WE WORKED OUT
THESE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUT
INTO THE BILL THAT MADE THEM
FEEL A LITTLE MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BILL. I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THE CHAIR LOVED THE BILL AT
THE END OF THE DAY, BUT HE WAS
WILLING TO ALLOW THE BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD. THESE ARE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AND WE ARE
NOT IN A POSITION NOW OF TAKING
THOSE OUT OF THE BILL, EVEN IF
WE WANT TO, BECAUSE THE BILL
WILL BE PULLED BACK INTO THE
ASSEMBLY AND INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT CAME FROM
THAT COMMITTEE. AND THAT'S JUST
HOW THE PROCESS WORKS. WE WERE
IN A COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
WHERE I ALMOST LOST ONE OF MY
BILLS THAT I'M VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT, SITTING NEXT TO THE GREAT
DOLORES HUERTA BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR DID NOT
NECESSARILY LIKE THE BILL THAT
WAS IN FRONT OF HER AND WANTED
TO AMEND THE BILL. WE DON'T, AS
AUTHORS, HAVE CONTROL OVER THAT,
BECAUSE THIS IS A GROUP
EXERCISE. IT'S A GROUP SPORT.
AND MANY TIMES PART OF THE
PROCESS IS OUR BILLS GET
CHANGED. THEY GET CHANGED BY THE
COMMITTEES. THEY GET CHANGED BY
THE CHAIRS. THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
IN THAT CASE, SO THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE. I COULDN'T TELL YOU, YOU
KNOW, I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE RATIONALE FOR A FOR ANOTHER
FOR A COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION
AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY
TOOK. THEY FELT COMFORTABLE
GOING UP TO 20 UNITS. THEY WERE
VERY ADAMANT ABOUT PUTTING ABOUT
THE EXEMPTION FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AS WELL. AND THAT WAS
OUR BARGAIN WITH THEM TO MOVE
THE BILL. OTHERWISE THE BILL
WOULD NOT HAVE MOVED AND WE'D
HAVE NOTHING AND NO PROTECTION
FOR ANY OF THESE LARGE BUILDINGS
THAT WERE GOING IN. SO THE
CHOICE WAS NOT MOVE THE BILL OR
MOVE IT IN THIS FORM. AND WE'VE
CHOSE TO I STILL THINK THAT IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL. I STILL
THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO PREVENT
WHAT WHAT THEY ARE FINDING,
WHICH IS VERY LARGE BUILDINGS
COMING IN AND OFFERING
PREFERENTIAL PARKING TO THEIR
USERS. AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THAT WHAT WE REALLY NEED IN
MIRACLE MILE IN PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES IS A MUCH MORE ROBUST
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND
AN ABILITY FOR ALL OF THEM TO
MAYBE HAVE LESS CARS, YOU KNOW,
SO THAT THEY CAN MOVE AROUND
THEIR CITY WITHOUT HAVING TO
DRIVE AROUND FOR HALF THE NIGHT
LOOKING FOR PARKING. I'VE LIVED.
I LIVED IN HOLLYWOOD BEFORE. I,
YOU KNOW, LIVED IN GLENDALE. I
KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE, AND I
KNOW MIRACLE MILE VERY WELL. I
KNOW THE AREA AROUND LACMA VERY
WELL. THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
PARKING CONSTRAINED PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES, WHERE YOU DO HAVE A MIX
OF OLD SINGLE FAMILY, OLD
APARTMENTS THAT ARE UNDER
PARKED, NEWER BUILDINGS,
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS, PEOPLE
GOING TO MUSEUMS, GOING TO ALL
KINDS OF THINGS, LOOKING FOR
PARKING AND WALKING ALL OVER OR
ALL AROUND. SO, YOU KNOW, THESE
ARE AREAS THAT THAT HAVE A LOT
OF STRESSORS, YOU KNOW, ON THEM
THAT YOU KNOW, THAT DO NEED TO
BE THE FOCUS OF, OF MOBILITY IN
OUR URBAN CORE. THANK YOU. SURE
YEAH. IT'S A GOOD COMMITTEE. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION? ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR CORTESE IS MOVED. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST. I AM
GLAD TO SEE THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD. I THINK THAT IT IS. YOU
KNOW, I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE PASS
LEGISLATION, THAT WE GO BACK AND
SEE HOW IT'S IMPACTING DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. AND I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELP.
IT MAY NOT BE PERFECT, BUT IT'S
THE BEST THAT WE COULD HAVE
GOTTEN OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY. AND
I DO HOPE THAT IT, YOU KNOW,
GIVES SOME CLARITY TO LOS
ANGELES AND GIVES THEM MORE
TOOLS TO KIND OF GET A HANDLE ON
THIS. AND WITH THAT, I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR A
DISTRICT BILL. GREAT. LET'S HAVE
A ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE AYE. CHOBOQ. NO. A CHOBOQ.
NO. BLAKE. SPEAR BLAKE. SPEAR.
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ CORTEZ.
AYE. MENGIBAR PADILLA. SATO.
UMBERG. WAHAB 3 TO 1. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS, AND THAT WILL BE ITEM.
OH, I'M SORRY. SHABBOS HERE. I
DIDN'T SEE HER. OH, SORRY.
APOLOGIES. WE WILL GO TO ITEM
FIVE AB 1820 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHOVAL. APOLOGIES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S BILLS WERE
VERY INTERESTING. I WAS HAPPY TO
BE HERE AND LISTEN, SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 1820.
AB 1820 HAS GOTTEN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, OVERWHELMING SUPPORT,
REALLY, BECAUSE IT'S A SIMPLE
GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE THAT
ALLOWS HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO
KNOW THAT DEVELOPMENT FEES PRIOR
TO COMMITTING SHOVELS TO THE
GROUND, KNOWLEDGE OF THESE FEES
ARE CRITICAL BECAUSE MANY OF
THESE FEES ADD UP TO 20% OF THE
COST OF A HOME, WHICH CAN BE THE
TIPPING POINT FOR MANY FROM
HAVING ACCESS TO AN AFFORDABLE
HOME. AB 1820 PROVIDES
GUARDRAILS, ESPECIALLY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOME DEVELOPERS, TO
HAVE PREDICTABILITY OF COST.
AFFILIATED WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED. DURING THE LAST
COMMITTEE HEARING, WE REMOVED
MOST, IF NOT ALL, OF THE
OPPOSITION CSAC, CAL FIRE CHIEFS
AND THE LEAGUE, ALONG WITH THE
PARKS AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAVE
ALL TAKEN NEUTRAL POSITIONS OR
SUPPORT POSITIONS OF THIS
MEASURE, AND WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE WORKING REALLY CLOSELY
WITH US. THE CITY OF OCEANSIDE
WAS THE ONLY OPPOSITION ON
RECORD THAT SUBMITTED A LATE
LETTER. OUR OFFICE HAS REACHED
OUT TO THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
SEVERAL TIMES AND NOT GOTTEN A
RESPONSE. HOWEVER, MOST OF THE
ISSUES IN THEIR LETTER WE'VE
ACTUALLY ALREADY ADDRESSED WITH
AMENDMENTS. SO HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE, I
HAVE BROOKE PRITCHARD FROM
CALIFORNIA, YIMBY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS BROOKE
PRITCHARD, AND I'M A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH CALIFORNIA YIMBY,
A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
80,000 MEMBERS DEDICATED TO
CREATING A MORE EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA THROUGH ABUNDANT,
SECURE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 1820, A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL WHICH ADDRESSES
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AND
PREDICTABILITY IN LOCAL
PERMITTING FEES. CURRENTLY,
DEVELOPERS FACE SUBSTANTIAL
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH LOCAL IMPACT
FEES, ALTHOUGH RECENT CHANGES
IMPROVE THE VIABILITY OF UPDATED
FEE SCHEDULES. CURRENTLY,
SEVERAL LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES DO
NOT HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
CONSOLIDATED FEE SCHEDULE. THIS
PIECEMEAL DISCLOSURE PROCESS NOT
ONLY INCREASES FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY, BUT CAN ALSO DELAY
OR DERAIL HOUSING PROJECTS
ALTOGETHER. AS THE AUTHOR HAS
STATED, THESE FEES CAN AMOUNT UP
TO UP TO 20% OF THE MEDIAN HOME
PRICE BY ALLOWING DEVELOPERS TO
REQUEST A FEE AND EXACTION
ESTIMATE IN GOOD FAITH FROM
THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THIS
BILL PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL PREDICTABILITY,
FACILITATING BETTER PLANNING AND
BUDGETING AMID CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS. THIS BILL IS A
PIVOTAL STEP TOWARD TRANSPARENCY
AND ENSURING WE BUILD THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE. THANK YOU. GREAT. LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. HOLLY, FOR MANY DAYS,
DUES WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF TWO
ADDITIONAL CO-SPONSORS AS THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SPUR AND
SUPPORTERS HABITAT FOR MANATEE
CALIFORNIA CIVIC WELL SANDHILL
PROPERTIES AND EDEN HOUSING ALL
IN SUPPORT. BOB NAYLOR FOR
FIELDSTEAD IN SUPPORT. STEPHEN
SENZA, WITH BROWNSTEIN ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT REBECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING LEADING AGE AND
SUPPORT MARY ELLEN SHEA,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY SUPPORT.
RALPH SONNENFELD, ON BEHALF OF
EMB ACTION AND SUPPORT. GREAT.
LET'S SEE, ANYONE ELSE SEEING
NONE? LET'S GO TO THE OPPOSITION
. ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES ON THE DAIS. GO
AHEAD, SENATOR OKUBO HAS MOVED
THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EXCELLENT. LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
A MOTION IS DUE. PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR SKINNER.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR.
PADILLA CIERTO. UMBRAL. WAHAB. 4
TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL
STAY ON CALL. AND NOW WE CAN GO
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS. AND
THAT ITEM IS. ITEM SIX AB 2022.
WELL, THANK YOU CHAIR. I WANT TO
SAY ALSO THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
AND THE ADVOCATES THAT ARE HERE
TODAY. I BRING YOU AB 2022, THE
MOBILE HOME EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ACT. IN RECENT
YEARS, AS YOU KNOW, NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS STORMS AND
WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN INCREASING
IN FREQUENCY, MAKING
COMPREHENSIVE EVACUATION PLANS A
MUST IN ORDER TO PROTECT THOSE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA, THE
CENTRAL COAST, WHERE I LIVE AND
REPRESENT, WAS HIT HARD BY THE
23 AND 24 WINTER STORMS, WITH
MANY COUNTIES IN THE REGION
BEING DECLARED MAJOR DISASTER
AREAS BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
DURING THESE STORMS AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS, MOBILE HOME
PARKS WERE ESPECIALLY
DEVASTATED, LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY DAMAGE AND
IN SOME CASES, LOSS OF LIFE.
WHILE EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
THESE PARKS TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN IN PLACE, SUCH
PLANS ARE NOT ALWAYS ACCESSIBLE,
NOR DO THEY ALWAYS HAVE CORRECT
INFORMATION. MOREOVER, THERE
HAVE BEEN INSTANCES WHEN
ESSENTIAL EMERGENCY ASSETS
ASSETS WERE NOT AVAILABLE FOR
USE BY RESIDENTS OR EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL. JUST ONE EXAMPLE IS
DURING THE TUBBS FIRE OF 2017,
WHEN RESIDENTS OF THE JOURNEY'S
END MOBILE HOME PARK WOKE UP TO
SEE THE FIRE HEADING TOWARDS THE
MAIN ENTRANCE OF THEIR PARK,
RENDERING IT UNUSABLE AS AN
EMERGENCY EXIT. FURTHERMORE, THE
OTHER LISTED ENTRANCES IN THAT
SITUATION WERE NOT OPEN AND HAD
NOT BEEN OPEN FOR YEARS,
ESSENTIALLY TRAPPING RESIDENTS
INSIDE. WHEN EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS ARRIVED ON THE SCENE,
THEY FOUND THAT THE FIRE
HYDRANTS WERE EITHER INOPERABLE
OR INACCESSIBLE, FORCING THEM TO
RELY ON THE WATER IN THEIR
TRUCK. WE CAN NO LONGER TAKE A
REACTIVE APPROACH TO THESE KINDS
OF DISASTERS AND MUST TAKE
PROACTIVE ACTION IN ORDER TO
SAVE LIVES. FORTUNATELY, WE DO
HAVE A SOLUTION. AB 2022 AIMS TO
MAKE SURE THESE, SECONDS THAT WE
ALL NEED DURING AN EMERGENCY
EVACUATION ARE NOT LOST. AND
THIS BILL DOES THREE THINGS.
FIRST, IT REQUIRES MORE
COMPREHENSIVE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLANS AND MAKES
SURE THAT THEY ARE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AT ALL TIMES. SECOND,
IT ENSURES THAT RESIDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO ENTRY AND EXIT POINTS,
UTILITY SHUT OFF CAPABILITIES,
AND WORKING FIRE HYDRANTS IN
CASE PARK MANAGEMENT IS OFF
SITE. AND FINALLY, THE BILL'S
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS WILL HOLD
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE PLANS.
WE ALSO HAVE ADOPTED AMENDMENTS
TO FURTHER CLARIFY THE ROLE OF
PARK OWNERS AND DESIGNEES IN
EMERGENCIES, AND CLARIFY THE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY'S ROLE IN
CERTIFYING COMPLIANCE. SO WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY ARE TWO
WITNESSES. KENDALL JARVIS FROM
LEGAL AID SONOMA AND BEVERLY
PURCELL, REPRESENTING GOLDEN
STATE MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS
LEAGUE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KENDALL JARVIS, AND I'M THE LEAD
DISASTER RELIEF ATTORNEY FOR
LEGAL AID OF SONOMA COUNTY. I'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH ADAM'S
OFFICE ON AB 2022, AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE YES ON THIS BILL,
AB 2022 IMPROVES EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE THAT MOBILE AND
MANUFACTURED HOME PARK RESIDENTS
ARE BETTER PREPARED FOR AND ABLE
TO RESPOND TO THE NEXT DISASTER.
SINCE 2015, CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
MORE DISASTERS THAN WE CAN
EASILY COUNT CONSISTENTLY. THESE
DISASTERS HAVE CAUSED THE LOSS
OF LIFE AND PROPERTY FOR MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. AB 2022 WILL BUILD
UPON THE CURRENT EMERGENCY PLAN
TO ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS AND
THEIR PROPERTY REMAIN SAFE AND
SAFELY HOUSED. AB 2022 WILL
IMPROVE EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE
THAT MOBILE AND MANUFACTURED
HOME PARK RESIDENTS CAN REMAIN
SAFE DURING THE NEXT DISASTER.
AB 2022 WILL REQUIRE MOBILE AND
MANUFACTURED PARK OWNERS AND OR
MANAGERS TO ENSURE EXITS AND
ENTRANCES REMAIN UNLOCKED SO
THEY CAN BE UTILIZED DURING AN
EMERGENCY. AB 2022 WILL REQUIRE
MOBILE AND MANUFACTURED HOME
PARK OWNERS AND OR MANAGERS TO
ENSURE THAT FIRE HYDRANT SYSTEMS
ARE WORKING AND REMAIN UNLOCKED
SO THAT THEY CAN BE UTILIZED
DURING AN EMERGENCY. BY
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL. AB 2022
WILL REQUIRE MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS AND OR MANAGERS TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO GAS SHUTOFF VALVES. IF
NEEDED. IN THE EVENT EMERGENCY
SHUTOFF IS NECESSARY. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE
YES ON AB 2022. MOBILE AND
MANUFACTURED HOME PARK RESIDENTS
DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO STAY
SAFE DURING AN EMERGENCY.
RESIDENTS DESERVE WORKING FIRE
HYDRANTS THAT ARE NOT LOCKED.
RESIDENTS DESERVE EMERGENCY
ACCESS TO EXITS AND ENTRANCES,
AND IN THE EVENT THAT THEY'RE
NEEDED DURING AN EMERGENCY,
RESIDENTS DESERVE TO KNOW THAT A
UTILITY PROVIDER CAN ACCESS AND
TURN OFF GAS WHEN NECESSARY TO
PREVENT A SECONDARY DISASTER.
I'M ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME, AND WE HOPE THAT YOU VOTE
YES ON AB 2022. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT? YES
GOOD AFTERNOON BEVERLY PURCELL
ON BEHALF OF GSM. ALL IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2022. FOR OVER 60 YEARS,
GSM MOBILE HAS BEEN OUR RESIDENT
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
ADVOCATING FOR SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOMES AND OTHER CALIFORNIANS
OF MODEST MEANS WHO LIVE IN
MOBILE HOMES. AB 22 2022 IS
CRITICAL AND LIFE SAVING. LIKE
MANY CALIFORNIANS, MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS HAVE SUFFERED THROUGH
NUMEROUS FIRES AND CONTINUED TO
WITNESS PREVENTABLE LOSS OF
LIVES AND PROPERTIES.
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES LIKE THE
SONOMA COMPLEX FIRES, PARADISE
FIRES, SYLMAR FIRE AND OTHERS
HAVE CAUSED MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS THEIR LIVES, THEIR
HOMES AND THEIR PROPERTIES. LAST
YEAR, COLONIAL MOBILE HOME PARK,
A SENIOR PARK LOCATED IN SAN
JOSE, WAS IMPACTED BY A FIRE
OVER THE 4TH OF JULY WEEKEND.
THE RESIDENTS OF THE PARK WERE
NOT GIVEN ACCESS TO THE BACK
EXIT, AND STRUGGLED TO FIND A
SAFE WAY OUT. MOBILE HOME PARK
RESIDENTS DESERVE BETTER. WE
DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO SAFELY
EVACUATE WHEN NECESSARY IN 2022,
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS PUBLISHED A STUDY IN
THEIR NATURAL HAZARDS REVIEW
THAT STUDY, PUBLISHED BY
PROFESSORS FROM UCLA AND SANTA
BARBARA UNIVERSITY, FOUND THAT
MOBILE HOMES ARE THE MOST LIKELY
OF ALL HOUSING TYPES TO BE
LOCATED IN AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
OR WILL BE IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRES. WITH ALL OF THE
KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE GLEANED,
MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY FACE
LOCKED ENTRIES AND EXITS, DO NOT
HAVE WORKING FIRE HYDRANTS, AND
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO GAS
SHUTOFF VALVES. WHEN MANAGEMENT
IS UNAVAILABLE. WE ARE ASKING
FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO HELP
IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
HI. I'M LINDA NÓI ON BEHALF OF
GSM. ALL IN SUPPORT. MICHELLE
MONNING I'M THE HOA PRESIDENT AT
ONE OF THE MOBILE HOME PARKS IN
ROSEVILLE. AND STRONG SUPPORT
JOSEPH NYE THE APPLE GIZMEL
SUPPORT. GREAT ANY OTHERS? ALL
RIGHT, LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. WE'LL
HAVE ONE KEY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. IS THAT CORRECT? IN
TERMS OF REGISTERING TWO, ARE
YOU TWO DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS?
YES, YES. WE'LL KEEP IT SHORT,
MADAM CHAIR. ALL RIGHT. WE ONLY
HAVE ONE REGISTERED. OKAY. HI.
MY NAME IS CHRIS WIECKOWSKI.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME. FIRST OF ALL, I
DO. I'M SORRY YOU'RE SPEAKING AS
AN INDIVIDUAL OR. NO, AS A
REPRESENTING W.M.A. I'M SORRY.
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOME
HOUSING COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION,
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME FIRST AGREE
THAT HAVING AN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN IS ESSENTIAL
TO PROVIDING TENANTS A SAFE
COMMUNITY. WE AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHY THE MRL ALREADY
REQUIRES PARKS TO HAVE THESE
PLANS IN PLACE, AND FOR THEM TO
BE POSTED AND PROVIDED TO
TENANTS IN THE PARK. THAT'S ALSO
WHY MANDATORY MANAGER PARK
TRAINING PROGRAM WAS BEING
DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW BY K¾T, AND
THIS WILL BEGIN NEXT YEAR. IT
INCLUDES A WHOLE SECTION ON
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS IN OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE, IT WAS ASSERTED THAT THE
KEY REASON FOR THE BILL IS NOW
MAKING SURE FIRE HYDRANTS CAN BE
UNLOCKED IN ARE PROPERLY
MAINTAINED IN THE EVENT OF A
FIRE THAT'S ALREADY CURRENT LAW.
LET ME BE CLEAR. TITLE 25,
SECTION 1317 IS AN ENTIRE CODE
DEALING WITH PRIVATE, PRIVATE
FIRE HYDRANT TESTING AND
CERTIFICATION. SO WE'RE NOT SURE
WHY THE BILL IS NECESSARY. IN
THE FIRST PLACE. PARKS ALREADY
HAVE TO TEST THEIR HYDRANTS
EVERY OTHER YEAR AS A CONDITION
OF RENEWING THEIR PTO. ALSO,
LOCKED HYDRANTS AREN'T USED IN
MOST CASES, AND EVEN IF THEY ARE
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT HAS A MASTER
KEY. WE ALSO ASK THE SPONSOR FOR
DATA ON ACTUAL DOCUMENTATION,
BUT WEREN'T PROVIDED WITH ANY.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT IT COULD BE USED AS
A WAY FOR TENANTS TO SUE A PARK
OWNER IF A DISASTER OCCURS. WE
CERTAINLY WON'T DEFEND PARKS
THAT BREAK THE LAW. THAT'S
INEXCUSABLE, BUT WE CERTAINLY
WON'T DEFEND PARKS THAT DESERVE
TO HAVE THEIR TOES REMOVED. WE
CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
VICTIMS OF FIRES AND FLOODS, BUT
AB 2022 IS A SOLUTION IN SEARCH
OF A PROBLEM. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A POTENTIAL FOR
CLAIMS OF LIABILITY AGAINST THE
PARK MANAGEMENT BASED ON ACTS OF
NATURE. THIS MEANS THAT
INSURANCE COSTS COULD BE MADE
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN
AND MORE EXPENSIVE. WE'RE STILL
AVAILABLE MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
INSURANCE COVERAGE RIGHT NOW. AN
INCREASE IN INSURANCE WILL
ULTIMATELY BE PASSED ON TO THE
TENANTS. EMERGENCY AND NATURAL
DISASTERS ARE BEST HANDLED BY A
LOCAL FIRST RESPONDERS AND
COUNTY FIRE MARSHALS, NOT PARK
RESIDENTS WHO HAPPEN TO HAVE THE
JOB OF A PARK MANAGER. FOR THESE
REASONS AND OTHERS LISTED IN OUR
LETTER, W.M.A IS OPPOSED TO AB
2022, AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS. JASON EICHER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE, AND I
WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE MR.
WYSOCKY COVERED A LOT OF THE
MAIN POINTS. I JUST WANT TO
ECHO, YOU KNOW, THE PARK OWNERS
THAT WE REPRESENT, YOU KNOW,
THEY THEY THEY THEY ALSO AGREE
THAT RESIDENT SAFETY IS
IMPORTANT. THEY OPERATE GOOD
PARKS AND THEY INTEND TO OPERATE
THEM SAFELY. BUT WE DON'T AGREE
THAT THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE SAFETY OR THAT IT IN
FACT WILL, AS MR. WYSOCKY NOTED,
WE ARE ALREADY ACTIVELY GOING TO
TRAIN PARK MANAGERS ON EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE, AND,
YOU KNOW, WE ALREADY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION UNDER EXISTING LAW TO
RESPOND IN A IN A TIMELY MANNER
TO ANY EMERGENCY AS NECESSARY.
WE DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
ADDITIVE. WE THINK WHAT'S
ADDITIVE IN THE BILL IS THE
ATTESTATION UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY. THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
REFERRED TO. AND IN SHORT, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, WE BELIEVE
THAT WHILE THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY, IT DOES IMPOSE
POTENTIAL, YOU KNOW, LIABILITY
ON PARK OWNERS AND A SIGNIFICANT
COST TO THE STATE OF $2.6
MILLION. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL AND REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE.
OKAY. ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE, LET ME
SEE IF, MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DAIS HAVE ANY. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CORTESE, YES. GO AHEAD. SENATOR
OCHOA, BOGH. I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS. SURE. SO I WAS IN
HOUSING WHEN WE PASSED, SENATOR
LEYVA'S BILL, 869 ON 20, 22,
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE PARK
MANAGERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
RECEIVE TRAINING ON ADDRESSING
EMERGENCIES AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROCEDURES, THIS
TRAINING ALSO ALREADY
COMPLEMENTS THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
PLANNING. SO IT APPEARS THAT AND
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SEVERAL
REQUIREMENTS BY THE STATE
ALREADY IN ORDER FOR THE PARKS
TO BE GIVEN THEIR PERMITS TO
OPERATE. SO THEY HAVE TO FULFILL
ALL OF THESE REQUIREMENTS,
SAFETY AND ALL OF THAT ON THAT
END. SO WITH REGARDS TO YOUR
PARTICULAR BILL, IT ALMOST SEEMS
REDUNDANT TO WHAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY HAVE. WHAT IS IT THAT
THEY'RE MISSING CURRENTLY THAT
WE DON'T ALREADY HAVE IN YOUR
CURRENT BILL? WHAT IS THAT YOU
HAVE OR OFFERING THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN HERE? NO, I THINK
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION.
MAYBE I'LL ASK OUR WITNESS TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
PART, BUT BROADLY, WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS,
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT,
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING AND MOBILE HOME HOUSING
IN GENERAL, GIVEN THE CHANGING
CLIMATE AND THE SEVERE WEATHER
EVENTS THAT WE'RE HAVING, IS AN
ITERATIVE PROCESS. AND SO WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO REVISIT HOW
WE'RE DOING THIS. BUT ON THE
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL CHANGES, I'LL
DEFER TO OUR WITNESS, IN TERMS
OF THE TRAINING SESSION THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, WHERE?
THAT IS A PROGRAM THAT IS NOW
CURRENTLY BEING FORMULATED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. SO IT'S NOT BASED
ON AB 2022. IF ANYTHING, IT
WOULD BE BASED ON PRIOR EXISTING
EMERGENCY REQUIREMENTS. AND IT'S
NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR HOW IMPACTFUL
THAT TRAINING PROGRAM WILL BE.
AND THEN FROM THE TECHNICAL
STANDPOINT, IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE REQUIRING THAT FIRE
HYDRANTS BE UNLOCKED SO THEY CAN
BE UTILIZED OR REQUIRING THAT
GAS SHUTOFF VALVES CAN BE
ACCESSED IN THE EVENT THAT THEY
NEED TO BE TURNED OFF. AND IT
DOESN'T DO THINGS LIKE REQUIRE
THAT SOMEONE BE PRESENT TO MAKE
SURE AN AN EXIT OR ENTRANCE CAN
BE UNLOCKED IN THE EVENT THAT
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY. SO AB
2022 VERY CLEARLY LAYS OUT WHERE
THERE WERE OBVIOUS HOLES AND
GAPS THAT WERE SHARED WITH US
THROUGH RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, AND THOSE WERE THE THREE
BIGGEST PIECES OF THE PUZZLE
THAT ARE POSING SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS. AND THREATS TO LIFE
AND SAFETY. SO REALLY, WE THINK
THAT AB 2022 TAKES THIS A STEP
FURTHER AND DOES WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO DO TO SAVE LIVES
AND I GUESS I GET THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL OF SAFETY OVERALL. BUT,
IF, IF AND SORRY, THE
REQUIREMENT BY THE PARKS TO
RECEIVE THIS TRAINING,
ADDRESSING EMERGENCIES AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PROCEDURES. AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND PLANNING. JUST
PASSED IN 2022. IT'S SB 869. SO
THE ENTITY THAT'S IN CHARGE OF
CREATING THIS THIS TRAINING, HOW
IS IT THAT YOU FOLKS ARE NOT
ACTUALLY ADVOCATING ON THAT END
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE THOSE
SPECIFICS, ITEMS THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED, AREN'T THERE, BUT SO
THAT'S ONE, ONE, ONE AREA. AND
THEN SECOND, LET'S SEE CURRENTLY
THE, THE GAS FACILITIES, ARE
INSPECTED BY THE GAS AND SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY. SO I COME FROM
A REAL ESTATE PERSPECTIVE AND A
REALTOR, AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE
DONE AND INSPECTED IN A CERTAIN
PERIOD FOR SAFETY PURPOSES,
INCLUDING THE GAS. AND SO FORTH,
SO, SO GOING BACK TO MY ORIGINAL
QUESTION, WHY IS IT THAT YOU
FOLKS ARE NOT GOING TOWARDS THE
ENTITY THAT'S ACTUALLY DEVISING
THE TRAINING TO INCLUDE THESE
COMPONENTS RATHER THAN GOING
THROUGH, A POLICY LEGISLATIVELY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE INSTEAD
OF ADDRESSING IT WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. AND THE
TRAINING, TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION SIMPLISTICALLY, WE HAVE
WE'VE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
PROVIDING FEEDBACK AND HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH HCD. I
THINK THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TRAINING BASED ON WHAT
EMERGENCY PROCEDURES SHOULD BE
IN TERMS OF WHAT SAFETY LOOKS
LIKE FROM A GENERAL STANDPOINT
VERSUS REQUIRING VERY SPECIFIC
THINGS. AND THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
TRAINING IS INTENDED TO DO. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY INTENDED TO BOLSTER
KNOWLEDGE OF BASIC EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND PLANNING. IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT MANAGEMENT
TAKE SPECIFIC STEPS TO ADDRESS
THOSE EMERGENCY NEEDS. IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. SO YES, WE HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN THAT,
AND WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE TO
ENSURE THAT, ESPECIALLY PARKS
THAT HAVE NEW MANAGEMENT OR
TURNOVER IN MANAGEMENT OR
HAVEN'T BEEN IMPACTED BY
DISASTERS THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF
WHAT REALLY HAPPENS ON THE
GROUND, BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY,
AS WE ALL KNOW, A LOT OF US
LEARNED THIS, YOU KNOW, FROM
2017 AND BEYOND, WHEN DISASTERS
CONTINUE TO GET MORE FREQUENT
AND LARGER IN SCALE. SO WITH THE
NUMBER OF DISASTERS WE HAVE, I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING MORE THAN JUST TRAIN
ON THE BASIS OF EMERGENCY
PLANNING OR PROCEDURES. FROM
THAT STANDPOINT, HOWEVER, I DO
LOVE THE IDEA THAT THE PROGRAM
IS THERE. I JUST THINK THIS BILL
GOES FARTHER AND TAKES ACTIVE
STEPS TO SAVE LIVES. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE'VE GOT A MOTION,
SENATOR CABALLERO, GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
MISSING PART OF THE HEARING. I
WAS LISTENING TO IT. I, YOU
KNOW, I THINK, I THINK PLANNING
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. THE THING
THAT STRUCK ME, IT WAS WHY WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME REQUIREMENT
TO ANY HOA OR ANY, APARTMENT
COMPLEX WITH MORE THAN, I DON'T
KNOW, 100 PEOPLE. IT JUST, IT'S
MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE IN SOME
COMMUNITIES, AND WE'RE LUCKY. I
MEAN, WE HAVE EARTHQUAKES. NOT
TORNADOES AND HURRICANES, SO
WE'RE LUCKY IN THAT REGARD, I
GUESS. BUT, BUT I WAS JUST THERE
. THE ONES THAT REALLY GET
TRASHED IN THE MOBILE HOMES
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO, THEY'RE SO
DELICATE. BUT I'M, I'M
WONDERING, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FLOOD RISKS AND FIRE
RISKS, WHY WHY ARE WE JUST
IDENTIFYING THEM, OR ARE YOU
GOING AT IT IN LITTLE PIECES?
WELL, I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
LOVE TO EXPAND THIS, IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING. I WOULD LOVE
TO EXPAND THIS TO COVER OTHER
TYPES OF HOMES. I DO THINK, YOU
KNOW, FOLKS THAT LIVE IN MOBILE
HOMES ARE OFTEN THE ONES IN THE
MOST NEED, RIGHT? IT'S OFTEN THE
FOLKS THAT ARE IN THE MOST
POVERTY, AND OFTEN IN AN OLDER
AGE OF POPULATION OR A
POPULATION, IN MY EXPERIENCE,
WHEN I WAS TOURING AFTER THE
JANUARY STORMS OF 2023, A
POPULATION THAT CAN HAVE VERY,
VERY LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKING
SKILLS AND READING SKILLS. AND
SO WE REALLY WANTED TO HIT THOSE
MOST IN NEED FIRST. BUT IF
YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT OTHERS
NEED THIS, ABSOLUTELY. I'M IN
AGREEMENT WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT.
I IT JUST IT JUST STRUCK ME AS
WE WERE LOOKING AT THIS, THAT, I
WHAT BROUGHT IT UP FOR ME, QUITE
FRANKLY, IS THAT, WE'RE LOOKING
AT TEMPERATURES, WELL, IN EXCESS
OF 100 DEGREES FOR THE NEXT TEN
DAYS. AND THE THAT VORTEX GOES
ABOVE. IT'S ABOVE SACRAMENTO ALL
THE WAY DOWN BELOW BAKERSFIELD.
AND IT WAS A RECORD SETTING YEAR
EITHER LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE WHEN FRESNO COUNTY HAD
TEN DAYS IN SEQUENCE OF OVER 100
DEGREES. THIS IS WELL OVER 100
DEGREES. AND I WORRY ABOUT
SENIORS THAT LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
EACH OTHER LIKE THEY USED TO,
OR, YOUNG COUPLES WITH BABIES
AND ALL. AND IN PARTICULARLY IN
MY DISTRICT, MANY OF THE HOMES
HAVE, THOSE SWAMP COOLERS.
THEY'RE AWFUL. I MEAN, THEY,
THEY, THEY MOVE THE AIR AROUND A
LITTLE BIT. THEY COOL IT A
LITTLE BIT, BUT THEY'RE NOT AIR
CONDITIONERS. AND SO THE IDEA
THAT YOU TRY TO, KEEP YOUR HOUSE
COOL WHEN IT NEVER COOLS DOWN
BELOW 90 DEGREES AT NIGHT, IT'S
DIFFICULT. AND SO I'M WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS WE'RE TAKING AND
WHETHER WE HAVE A LONG TERM
SYSTEM JUST TO CHECK ON PEOPLE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING? DO YOU NEED
WATER? IS THERE SOMETHING WE CAN
DO TO HELP YOU, AND IN
PARTICULAR, PEOPLE OVER THE AGE
OF 80. SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE, YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE. I JUST WONDERED IF YOU HAD
THOUGHT BEYOND THAT. AND
SOMETIMES IT'S EASIER TO BITE
OFF THINGS IN SMALL PIECES, SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT. NO, I MEAN
POINT POINT WELL TAKEN. AND
THAT'S WHY I MENTIONED WITH THE,
EXTREME HEAT THAT WE'RE FACING,
THE OTHER KIND OF MEGA STORMS,
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS THAT
EMERGENCY PLANNING HAS TO BE AN
ITERATIVE PROCESS. AND,
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
EXPAND THAT KIND OF PLANNING AND
GREW UP WITH A SWAMP COOLER IN A
VERY HOT DESERT AND KNOW HOW
VERY, VERY CHALLENGING THAT IS
ON A TRULY HOT DAY. TO HAVE THAT
AS YOUR ONLY WAY TO COOL DOWN
AND, AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY FOR FOLKS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING OVER THE PAST
NUMBER OF WEEKS, LACK OF CLEAN
WATER AND LACK OF ABILITY TO
COOL DOWN. THANK YOU. ONE
SECOND. SO IF WE'RE COMPLETE, DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? BEFORE I EVER CLOSE,
I THINK SO WE COULD TAKE THE
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. OKAY, LET'S HAVE A ROLL
CALL. A MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR SKINNER,
I SKINNER, I ATROPOS, BLAKE
SPEAR, BLAKE SPEAR I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR PADILLA. SERRATO.
UMBERG THAT'S 4 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL WILL STAY ON CALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
LET'S GO TO THAT. THAT IS ITEM
TEN AB 2488. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR, PRESENTING AB 2488, WHICH
IS OUR, DOWNTOWN REVITALIZATION
BILL FOR SAN FRANCISCO. IT IS A
DISTRICT BILL, AS YOU ALL KNOW,
DURING COVID 19, WE HAD
DEVASTATING EFFECTS. MANY OF OUR
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO WAS NOT
UNIQUE. WE UNFORTUNATELY, ARE
STILL TRYING TO RECOVER, PEOPLE
HAVE NOT COME BACK TO WORK. WE
HAVE A VACANCY, A RECORD
BREAKING VACANCY ABOUT
32,000,000FT². THIS IS AN EFFORT
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING WHAT
WE CAN TO BRING PEOPLE BACK
DOWNTOWN IN GIVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONVERT OFFICE
BUILDINGS INTO HOUSING. LET ME
JUST START BY SAYING I ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THAT I AM,
PROMISING NOT TO TAKE THE BILL
UP ON THE FLOOR UNTIL THE LABOR
LANGUAGE IS SORTED OUT IN
CONSULTATION WITH ALL THE
COMMITTEES THAT HAVE
JURISDICTION ON THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
TO BRING OUR STRUGGLING DOWNTOWN
BACK TO VIBRANCY. I HAVE LEWIS
FERRANTE HERE FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AS MY WITNESS. GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS LUIS
MORANTE. ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL, ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL,
I WAS REALLY PROUD TO WORK WITH
A VERY LARGE GROUP OF OUR
MEMBERS WHO INCLUDE MANY OF THE
PROPERTY OWNERS AND DEVELOPERS
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO, TO
PUT FORWARD SOMETHING THAT WE
FEEL VERY STRONGLY WILL HELP SAN
FRANCISCO WILL LEAD TO
PRODUCTION, WILL LEAD TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. THIS BILL IS NARROWLY
TARGETED AT SAN FRANCISCO'S
EXISTING 40 MILLION, ABOUT
SQUARE FEET OF VACANT OFFICE IN
SAN FRANCISCO. THAT ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT 40% OF ALL THE OFFICE
SPACE IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THAT VACANCY IS A BIG REASON
WHY DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO HAS
SUCH A PROBLEM WITH KEEPING
STOREFRONTS OPEN, WITH FOOT
TRAFFIC, WITH CRIME, WITH ALL OF
THESE THINGS THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT
IN THE NEWS, THOSE PERCEPTIONS
OF SAN FRANCISCO ARE A BIG
PROBLEM THAT THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS DOWNTOWN REVITALIZATION
HERE. I LIKE TO SAY, IS THE
GOAL. WHILE HOUSING IS THE
STRATEGY FOR ACCOMPLISHING THAT
GOAL, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT THIS BILL, AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
IT. THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, PAUL YODER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND MARYLAND AND
BREED ALSO IN SUPPORT. BROOKE
PRITCHARD, ON BEHALF OF SPUR AND
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. SEEING ANY
OTHERS? NOT SO. LET'S USE AN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MOTION,
PLEASE. SOME QUESTION. OKAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR CABALLERO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING, YOU MAY
CLOSE, THANK YOU AGAIN. ÁP 2488
IS A CRITICAL TOOL TO HELPING
BRING BACK VIBRANCY TO OUR
DOWNTOWN. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE. OKAY, LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE OKOBOJI. BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ.
AYE. MENGIBAR. PADILLA CIERTO.
UMBRAL. WAHAB. IT'S 4 TO 0.
THANK YOU. GREAT. IT'LL BE ON
CALL. WE'LL HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS
COME IN AT SOME POINT. OKAY.
LET'S SEE. LET'S HAVE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD PRESENT YOUR BILL.
AND THAT IS ITEM. 17 AB 3093.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU,
CHAIR SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3093. I'LL
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. AB 3093
REFINES AND ENHANCES OUR PRIMARY
HOUSING PLANNING PROCESS, THE
RENA PROCESS, TO INCLUDE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS,
THOSE EXPERIENCING AND AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS. AB 3093 COMES
DIRECTLY FROM HCD'S REPORT ON
RECOMMENDED. RENA REFORMS.
HOMELESSNESS IS FUNDAMENTALLY A
HOUSING PROBLEM AND THE STATE
CANNOT FIX WHAT IT DOES NOT
TRACK. RENA IS OUR MAIN TOOL FOR
PLANNING FOR THE HOUSING NEEDS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE LOWEST
INCOME CATEGORY IN THE RENA
RIGHT NOW RANGES FROM 0 TO 50%
OF THE AREA. MEDIAN INCOME OR
AMI, AND THAT IS VERY BROAD.
MOST HOUSING IN THIS CATEGORY
ENDS UP BEING AFFORDABLE TO
THOSE EARNING CLOSER TO 50% OF
THE AMI. LEAVING CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE LOWEST INCOMES
UNDERSERVED. IN RESPONSE, AB
3093 INTRODUCES TWO NEW INCOME
CATEGORIES TO THE RENA PROCESS
FOR THE NEXT HOUSING ELEMENT
CYCLE. THE ACUTELY LOW INCOME
AND EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
CATEGORIES. THESE CATEGORIES
CAPTURE THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS, EARNING UP TO 15
AND 30% OF AMI, RESPECTIVELY. AB
3093 WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE SPECIAL
HOUSING NEEDS OF THESE LOWEST
EARNERS AND THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS. THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DO NOT HAVE TO GO ABOUT THIS
ALONE. HCD WOULD DEVELOP
GUIDANCE TO HELP THEM CRAFT
THESE PROGRAMS TO GET TO THE
DEEPLY AFFORDABLE, PERMANENT
HOUSING THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED. WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO
SO. SHOULD THIS PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR, THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS NOT TO ALTER HOW
THE CURRENT HOUSING ELEMENT
SITES INVENTORY PROCESS WORKS.
THIS BILL IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET. WE MUST DO MUCH MORE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. BUT AB
3093 WILL HELP US PLAN FOR OUR
HOUSING FUTURE WITH UNHOUSED
CALIFORNIANS IN MIND, AND HOLD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING THOSE PLANS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS MEGAN
KIRKEBY FROM HCD. ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION,
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AND
WHEN THE TIME COMES, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. MEGAN
KIRKEBY, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HCD,
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW FOR GREATER TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN OUR
HOUSING GOALS, AS WAS JUST
DESCRIBED, AND YES, THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN, THIS IS NOT
REQUIRING DIFFERENT ZONING
PROCEDURES SPECIFIC TO THIS
POPULATION. THE ZONING
EXPECTATIONS ARE THE SAME FOR
ALL OF THE LOWER INCOME HOUSING,
BUT IMPACTS THE SPECIAL NEEDS
ANALYSIS, WHERE LOCALS ARE ASKED
TO ANALYZE AT RISK POPULATIONS
AND DEVELOP THOSE POLICIES
WITHIN THEIR CONTROL THAT HELP
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. AND, THE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED THE
ZONING CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE HITTING THAT INTENT
THAT WERE EXPRESSED PREVIOUSLY,
BUT ALWAYS OPEN TO MORE
DISCUSSION, WE ALSO RECEIVE SOME
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL ASKING FOR
MORE HCD GUIDANCE ON THE SPECIAL
NEEDS ANALYSIS CONSTRAINTS AND
DEVELOPMENT FEASIBILITY. PARTS
OF THE HOUSING ELEMENT. WE THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA. YOU'LL SEE
THOSE REPRESENTED IN THE BILL AS
WELL. AND IMPORTANT TO NOTE, ALL
HOUSING, NOT JUST AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, IS PROTECTED BY THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
THE AFFORDABILITY LEVEL CANNOT
BE USED AS A REASON TO DENY
HOUSING. WE DO MAKE THAT REALLY
CLEAR IN OUR HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT GUIDANCE
THAT'S OUT RIGHT NOW. AND SO
JUST FOR ANYONE THAT'S CONCERNED
THAT THIS MIGHT BE USED IN THAT
PARTICULAR WAY, OUR HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT HAS ALREADY
ADDRESSED SITUATIONS WHERE THAT
HAS COME UP AND MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT DOES NOT
PERMIT, DOES NOT PERMIT THAT
BEHAVIOR. SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THAT TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY, AND A FOCUS
ON POLICY ACTIONS FOR THIS, THE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES OF THESE
POPULATIONS IS A IS A POSITIVE
IS A POSITIVE MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. STEPHEN CENSOR WITH
BROWN SEEING ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AND MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE? ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS.
CAROLINE GRINDER, ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES,
CAL CITIES IS RESPECTFULLY
MAINTAINING OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB 1393.
DESPITE THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS SINCE THE
BILL HAS BEEN INTRODUCED. I'M
AND APPRECIATE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND HCD,
UNFORTUNATELY, WE CONTINUE
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED THAT
THIS MEASURE IS CREATING NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DEVELOP
THE PLANS OR IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAMS, OR SPUR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT WE'RE PLANNING FOR.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED, AB 1393
REQUIRES CITIES TO IDENTIFY
SITES AND DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING. FOR ALI AND ELLIE
HOUSEHOLDS, BUT IT LACKS
CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THESE SITES AND PROGRAMS SHOULD
DIFFER FROM WHAT CITIES ARE
ALREADY PLANNING FOR THROUGH THE
EXISTING VERY LOW INCOME
CATEGORY. ADDITIONALLY, WHILE AB
1393 SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF HOMELESS RESIDENTS, EXISTING
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES CITIES TO ANALYZE THE
SPECIAL HOUSING NEEDS OF
HOMELESS RESIDENTS AND ASSIST IN
DEVELOPING ADEQUATE HOUSING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME POPULATION. THROUGH
THESE EXISTING PLANNING EFFORTS,
WE BELIEVE THAT CITIES ARE DOING
MORE THAN EVER TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF UNHOUSED RESIDENTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES, RATHER THAN
DUPLICATE THOSE PLANNING
EFFORTS, WE DO FEEL THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD FOCUS ON
INVESTING, FUNDING AND
CHANNELING DIRECTLY TO CITIES SO
THAT THEY CAN INVEST THOSE FUNDS
AND SPUR THE NEEDED DEVELOPMENT,
ADDING ADDITIONAL INCOME
CATEGORIES TO RINA AT A TIME
WHERE THE STATE BUDGET INCLUDES
1.1 BILLION IN CUTS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS,
DOESN'T MOVE US FORWARD IN
MEETING OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GOALS, CITIES ACROSS THE STATE
ARE PLANNING AND APPROVING
MILLIONS OF NEW HOMES AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS, DESPITE NEW BILLS
INTRODUCED EVERY YEAR THAT HAVE
CHANGED THE RULES MIDSTREAM
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERING CITY'S
HOUSING ELEMENT CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. WITH CITIES STILL
NAVIGATING THE STATE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR THE
SIXTH CYCLE, WE DON'T BELIEVE
NOW IS THE TIME TO ADD THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS THAT COULD ONLY ADD
FURTHER DELAYS TO THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS, AND WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH ADDRESSING
THE INTENT OF THIS MEASURE,
WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, BOOSTING THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE JUST WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THIS ADDED
CLARITY ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THESE PROGRAMS AND SITES
SO THAT WE DON'T SET OUR CITIES
UP TO FAIL. SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO BOLSTER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON AB 1393.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION? ALYSSA SALEHI ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA, I'M RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. UNLESS AMENDED. AND THEN
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CORONA AND CARLSBAD. OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. KIARA
ROSS. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SOLANA BEACH, OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED, ECHOING THE CONCERNS OF
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHERS? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER OPPOSITION, LET'S GO TO
THE DÍAS SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
YES. THANK YOU, SO I SUPPORT
THIS BILL, AND I THINK IT'S,
CONCEPTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WHEN WE ARE ASKING CITIES TO DO
PLANNING FOR HOUSING, WE ARE
ASKING THEM TO DO PLANNING FOR
HOMELESS SERVING HOUSING. SO IT
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE ANY SENSE TO
HAVE A RINA PROCESS THAT STOPS
AT LOW INCOME HOUSING AND
DOESN'T GO ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
UNHOUSED. SO I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND THAT
HCD HAS WORKED SO CLOSELY WITH
THE LEGISLATURE, THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH TO COME UP WITH THIS
BILL. I THINK I WAS LISTENING
VERY CLOSELY TO MISS KIRKEBY. IT
WAS NICE TO SEE YOU HERE AT THIS
HEARING, AND IN THE END, AT THE
END, YOU SAID THAT THIS IS A
POLICY FOCUSED APPROACH OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND I
THINK, THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE CONTINUE TO
ITERATE ON THESE MANY LAWS THAT
WE HAVE THAT FOCUS ON
HOMELESSNESS, PARTICULARLY, THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE AN OBLIGATION FOR EVERY CITY
AND EVERY MUNICIPALITY TO MANAGE
HOMELESSNESS THAT THEY SEE
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS. AND
I THINK THAT WE HAVE A REALITY
WITH MORE THAN 400 CITIES AND
COUNTIES, THAT THERE ARE SOME
WHO ARE TRYING AND DOING A LOT,
AND THERE ARE A LOT THAT DON'T
REALLY WANT TO ACTUALLY HAVE TO
BE INVOLVED IN THE SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS, WHETHER THAT'S
SHELTER, SHORT TERM OR MID-TERM
OR LONG TERM. AND SO RIGHT NOW,
THE RINA PROCESS IS AN
OBLIGATION FOR CITIES AND SOME
CITIES FIND IT VERY HARD TO
MANAGE, LIKE THE ONE THAT I COME
FROM. AND I RECOGNIZE HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS TO GET AN
APPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT. BUT I
ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE HOUSING
IN THE CITY OF ENCINITAS THAT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE IF NOT FOR THE
OBLIGATION, BECAUSE WE HAD TO
ZONE AND PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD NOT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS
NEEDED, THAT WOULD NOT BE THERE
OTHERWISE. AND I THINK THAT SAME
CONCEPT CAN BE APPLIED TO
HOMELESS SERVING HOUSING, THAT
WE WOULD END UP WITH PROJECTS
THAT WOULD NOT BE THERE
OTHERWISE. IF WE CREATE THE
OBLIGATIONS AND THE REQUIREMENTS
AROUND HOMELESS SERVING HOUSING.
SO THIS I SEE THIS BILL AS A
FIRST STEP, AND BUT I DO WONDER
IF THERE WILL BE ANY HOMELESS
SERVING HOUSING CREATED BECAUSE
OF THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS. IT
DOES SEEM VERY THEORETIC AND
POLICY ORIENTED AT THE MOMENT,
AND NOT NOT MAYBE AS ON THE
GROUND AS WOULD CREATE ACTUAL
THE ACTUAL HOMELESS SERVING
HOUSING IN ANY CATEGORY. BUT I
ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY, FOR THE
RECORD, THAT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND INSTRUCTIVE TO
REMEMBER THAT SITING CONTINUES
TO BE A MAJOR PROBLEM. AND IN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO, WHICH
BOTH OF US REPRESENT, THE AUTHOR
AND I REPRESENT, THERE IS AN
ONGOING MAJOR DEBATE ABOUT A
SHELTER THAT IS WOULD SERVE A
THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND PART OF THE
REASON FOR CENTERING THAT MANY
PEOPLE ALTOGETHER IS THAT IT'S
VERY HARD TO FIND ENOUGH SITES
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE. ALL THROUGHOUT THE LARGE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO, AND, AND SO
DEALING WITH THE SITING AND
HAVING CITIES WRESTLE WITH THAT
AND THAT BEING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND LAND USE DECISION
THAT'S MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
THAT DOES SEEM THAT IS THE
PROCESS WE HAVE. AND SO IF WE'RE
LEANING INTO THAT, I THINK WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
OBLIGATIONS FOR ALL CITIES TO DO
THEIR PART AND NOT EXPECT THE
BIG CITIES TO SHOULDER ALL OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR HOMELESS,
SERVING, HOUSING. SO I SUPPORT
THIS AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES FORWARD, BUT I DO
ENCOURAGE US TO CONTINUE TO BE
AMBITIOUS AND FOR HCD TO PLAY AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN SAYING WHAT YOU
SEE, BECAUSE YOU CERTIFY ALL
CITIES HOUSING ELEMENTS THAT
COULD MAKE THE DIFFERENCE WHEN
IT COMES TO PROVIDING HOMELESS,
SERVING HOUSING, WHICH WE KNOW
IS A TOP CRISIS IN THIS STATE
AND IS LITERALLY GETTING WORSE
EVERY MONTH. AND WE ARE WE ARE
NOT CHANGING THINGS AT A SYSTEMS
LEVEL THAT WOULD CHANGE THE
OUTCOME. SO IT WILL CONTINUE TO
GET WORSE. AND I HOPE THAT AT
SOME POINT WE WILL HAVE A
SYSTEMS LEVEL CHANGE THAT WILL
LEAD TO A DIFFERENT OUTCOME ON
THE STREETS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, I WILL TAKE YOUR AS A
MOTION SINCE TO NOW IS THE TIME
TO MAKE MOTIONS. SO OKAY. BUT
YES, I WILL ALSO CALL ON SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I'M NOT AS SYMPATHETIC TO
DESPITE THE FACT THAT I DON'T.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME TO HAVE
OBJECTION AROUND THE RENA
PROCESS HERE, BUT I THINK AS FAR
AS CHANGES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTING RENA, THE HITS ARE
JUST GOING TO KEEP COMING IN,
IT'S UNFORTUNATE, HAVING BEEN
HAVING PRESIDED OVER THAT
PROCESS IN THE BAY AREA IN MY
PAST. IT, YOU KNOW, IT'S A VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS ALREADY,
BUT, WE'VE GOT TO CONTINUE
MAKING MODIFICATIONS TO IT, TO
SOME MEMBER WARD THAT IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, I FELT LIKE MY
HOME COUNTY. WE'VE DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF TAKING THE EOC
CATEGORY AND USING IT FOR, YOU
KNOW, BASICALLY $1 BILLION IN
LOCAL FUNDING FOR, PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. YOU KNOW,
STANDING UP AN OFFICE OF AGING
SERVICES AND SO FORTH. WHERE DO
YOU SEE THE ROI ADDING TO THAT?
I'M NOT UNSUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
BILL. I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE NECESSITY OF THAT
FROM A, FROM A FINANCING OR
FISCAL STANDPOINT OR, OR
OTHERWISE. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. AND
THANK YOU AS WELL, SENATOR, FOR
YOUR EARLY SUPPORT AND
CO-AUTHORSHIP OF THIS AS WELL, I
THINK ONE THING I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE IS, KIND OF CRYSTAL CLEAR
IS THAT THIS IS INTENDED TO BE
ABLE TO GO INTO EFFECT FOR THE
SEVENTH HOUSING CYCLE, RIGHT,
WHICH WILL BEGIN IN 2028. SO BY
PASSING THIS LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR, THIS GIVES US A FOUR YEAR
RUNWAY TO BEGIN TO THINK
THROUGH. HOW ARE WE ACTUALLY
GOING TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS?
RINA IS AN EXISTING PROCESS AND
EVOLVING PROCESS. WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN ABOUT IT EVERY SUCCESSIVE
CYCLE ABOUT HOW TO MAKE IT WORK,
ACTUALLY HOW TO CONNECT THE
DOTS. BOTH THROUGH STATE
POLICIES, CERTAINLY STATE
FUNDING, WHICH I ARGUE WE NEED
TO DO MORE OF AS WELL, BUT IT
REALLY CHALLENGES EACH LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
WITHIN ITSELF ABOUT LOCAL
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN BE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT THROUGH
SITING, THROUGH ZONING, BUT ALSO
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND MAYBE LOCAL
FUNDING RESOURCES AS WELL THAT
CAN MEET THAT. SO TO AN AREA
LIKE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OR
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN YOUR COUNTY
THAT ARE HAVING THAT SUCCESS,
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDING, THAT
HAVE BEEN CITING, THAT SHOULD
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO BE COUNTED
TOWARDS THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN THE Â CATEGORY. NOW
ELI CURRENTLY IS, YOU KNOW,
ENUMERATED TO A DEGREE BUT IS
NOT PART OF THE BROADER, VERY
LOW INCOME CATEGORY THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO SEE FROM A GOAL
SETTING STANDPOINT. AND SO IT'S
TOUGH TO TEASE OUT THERE'S A
HUGE DISTINCTION IN, IN VERY
LARGE POPULATIONS, WHEN YOU
REALLY SCALE THAT OUT TO
SOMETHING, THE SIZE OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE BETWEEN 30 AND
50, 15 AND 30, AND ZERO AND 15%
ESSENTIALLY NEAR ZERO INCOME, OR
THOSE THAT ARE AT RISK OF
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
AT ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT STRATA
HAVE POLICIES THAT ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO HELP HOUSING
SOLUTIONS THAT SUPPORT THEM AS
WELL. I THINK IS THE ULTIMATE
GOAL THAT WE WANT TO SEE FROM
THE 2028 THROUGH 2036. TIME
FRAME, WORK, OF COURSE, WITH OUR
LOCAL CITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING, WHETHER
THROUGH ITS TEMPLATE. OR
GUIDANCE OR OTHER SERVICES THAT
HCD CAN BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. BUT
THE IDEA THERE IS THAT WE NEED
TO START TO TEASE THOSE OUT AS A
GOAL, A GOAL THAT IS REFLECTED
IN THE ACTUAL DATA THAT WE'RE
GETTING FROM COUNTIES ABOUT THE
POPULATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
SERVE, AND THEN BETTER FINE TUNE
THE POLICIES TOWARDS THOSE
DEEPLY AFFORDABLE, POPULATIONS.
THAT OR SORRY, THE POPULATIONS
THAT NEED DEEPLY AFFORDABLE,
AFFORDABILITY. YEAH. THROUGH THE
CHAIR I'M. YES I'M NOT 100%
SOLD, BUT I'M SOLD ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. SO LET'S SEE
HOW IT HOW IT ROLLS OUT. IT
STRIKES ME AS SOMETHING THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT BE SO NECESSARY. BUT
IT COULD BE JUST MY PERSPECTIVE
AGAIN, IN MY OWN COUNTY WHERE IF
YOU'RE 0 TO 30% AMI, YOU'RE,
YOU'RE EFFECTIVELY YOU'RE
FUNCTIONALLY HOMELESS OR YOUR
FAMILY IS SO FAR BELOW THE
FEDERAL ADJUSTED POVERTY LEVEL
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT ISN'T A
MATTER OF US. NEEDING TO TEASE
THAT OUT ANYMORE. IT'S A MATTER
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO SCALE THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR THAT
, FOR THAT POPULATION, WHICH IS
A DIFFERENT ISSUE. THAT'S NOT
YOUR BILL ANYWAY. I'LL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. AND, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO, SENATOR CABALLERO,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. WELL, I WON'T I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT. I, I, I LIKE
TEASING IT OUT, BUT I LIKE
TEASING IT OUT BECAUSE MY
PERCEPTION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT, WHICH IS NOT NOT THAT
IT'S A BIG CITIES THAT ARE DOING
THE HOMELESS. WORK, BUT THAT
IT'S, WEALTHY COMMUNITIES THAT
SAY WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY THAT
HERE THAT'S HOMELESS OR WE DON'T
HAVE VERY MANY HOMELESS IN OUR
COMMUNITY, AND, AND SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT IT CREATES
THE OBLIGATION FOR EVERYBODY TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MEET THEIR THEIR
HOMELESS POPULATION AND THEN TO
SHOW SOME SUCCESS TO HCD, IT
IT'S, WE'VE DONE A LOT OF THINGS
TO AND I AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
LEAGUE OF CITY'S POSITION, WHICH
IS LOOK, YOU KEEP CHANGING THE
RULES AND EVERY TIME WE TURN
AROUND, THERE'S A NEW WE'VE GOT
TO ADAPT TO A NEW RULE. AND
THAT'S IT'S REALLY TRUE. WE
PROBABLY SHOULD PUT A HIATUS ON
CHANGING THINGS TOO MUCH MORE SO
THAT WE CAN SEE IF IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING. AND, AND THAT THE SAME
THING IS FRUSTRATES ME ABOUT THE
HOMELESS MONEY WE'VE PUT OUT
THERE. WE DIDN'T PUT ANY
CATEGORIES. THAT SAID, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BUY A HOTEL, IT SHOULD
BE HELD IN PUBLIC HANDS AND IT
SHOULD REMAIN IN PUBLIC HANDS.
AND, AND SO THERE ARE PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS THAT GOT A WHOLE HECK
OF A LOT OF MONEY TO DO SOME OF
THIS WORK, AND TO CONTRACT WITH,
WITH THE NONPROFITS THAT ARE
BRINGING IN THE HOMELESS. BUT WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THAT AND
UNLESS THE MONEY KEEPS GOING OUT
FROM THE STATE, THERE'S NO WAY
FOR SOME OF THOSE FACILITIES TO
CONTINUE TO OR THOSE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUE GOING.
SO IT JUST, SOMETIMES, WE'VE GOT
TO BE A LITTLE BIT WISER ABOUT
HOW WE HOW WE STRUCTURE OUR
PROGRAMS, WHAT OUR EXPECTATIONS
ARE AND, AND WHAT ARE THE MODELS
THAT ARE GOING TO WORK SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS AND NOT TEMPORARILY
AND THEN SAY, SORRY, BUT WE LOST
FUNDING AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE, SO I THINK THIS STARTS
TO TELL US INFORMATION, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS. THANK YOU. SENATOR ALL
RIGHT. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION,
AND, YOU CAN CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I WOULD JUST REALLY
SUMMARIZE BY RECOGNIZING THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE A PROCESS AND
IMPERFECT THAT IT IS, AND WE'RE
ALL COMMITTED TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUPPORT SOME REFORMS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELP TO
IMPROVE, NOT JUST THE
ENUMERATION OF WHAT WE NEED TO
DO UNDER THAT PROCESS, BUT ALSO
OUR STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THESE GOALS HARDER AND
HARDER THAN THEY ARE WITH EACH
PASSING YEAR, WHAT THIS DOES IS
REALLY HELPS US LOOK FORWARD FOR
THE PLANNING, THE NEXT PLANNING
CYCLE AND THROUGH THAT EXISTING
PROCESS, RECOGNIZING, AS I SAID
BEFORE, THAT THERE ARE VERY
SPECIFIC AND VERY SPECIAL NEEDS
FOR A STRUGGLING AND VERY
VULNERABLE SUBPOPULATION OF THAT
VERY LOW INCOME CATEGORY. AND TO
BE ABLE TO GOAL SET THAT USING
EDUCATIONAL DATA, USING THE
POINT IN TIME COUNT DATA, USING
OUR GIS DATA, WHICH YOU'RE ALSO
IMPROVING TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE THE GOALS AND WHAT
ARE THE TARGETS. AND I AGREE
WITH SENATOR AS WELL, SENATOR
CABALLERO, THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MORE EFFECTIVE
WITH A LOT OF AND ACCOUNTABLE
WITH A LOT OF OUR INVESTMENTS
THAT INFORMS OUR BUDGET
DECISIONS FOR THE NEXT YEAR. SO
WE KNOW IF A PROGRAM IS WORKING
AND IS A BETTER BANG FOR BUCK ON
PRODUCING MORE UNITS, THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT AS A
STATE TOWARDS THOSE
JURISDICTIONS WILLING TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THOSE, THOSE DOLLARS,
THE MAXIMAL NUMBER OF UNITS THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO PRODUCE. BUT IT
REALLY STARTS WITH AN EIGHT YEAR
LOOK AHEAD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE, ALIGNING WHAT THE NEED IS
THERE THROUGH GOAL SETTING FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE CATEGORIES,
AND THEN WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE CITIES,
WHICH WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO. SO
SHOULD THIS GET OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS
WORKABLE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
BEST FAITH EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO
TRY TO MEET THOSE GOALS IN THE
NEAR FUTURE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL. MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED, AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. SENATOR SKINNER,
I SKINNER I, OKUBO, MØT, BLAKE
SPEER, BLAKE. SPEER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I COURTESY CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR. PADILLA SERRATO.
UMBERG 4 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL HOLD THAT. AND, UNTIL WE
GET MORE MEMBERS. AND MEANWHILE,
LET ME SEE. DO I HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM, YES. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU CAN, PRESENT FOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO, ITEM
NINE, AB 2485.
WE ALREADY DID, SANTIAGO. RIGHT
YES. HANEY. YEAH. OKAY THAT'S
OKAY, ANYTIME YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB 2485 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. FIRST, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAREY, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. HE
WILL ALSO RESPECTFULLY BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS CALCULATION
PROCESS BY REQUIRING HCD TO
ENGAGE IN A SINGLE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AT THE START OF EACH
ARENA CYCLE AND REQUIRES THE
PUBLICATION OF METHODOLOGIES
USED ON HCD'S WEBSITE. THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, OR ARENA, IS A STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM THAT REQUIRES
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING FOR EXPECTED POPULATION
GROWTH. GROWTH OVER AN EIGHT
YEAR PLANNING PERIOD.
COMMUNITIES USE ARENA IN THEIR
LAND USE PLANNING, PRIORITIZING
LOCAL RESOURCE ALLOCATION TO
ADDRESS IDENTIFIED HOUSING NEEDS
RESULTING FROM POPULATION,
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSEHOLD GROWTH.
IN MARCH 2022, THE STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCTED AN EMERGENCY AUDIT TO
EXAMINE THE ARENA PROCESS AND
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL ERRORS IN
HCD'S HOUSING PROJECTIONS THAT
RESULTED IN A DECREASE IN THE
ALLOCATED HOUSING NUMBERS. AND I
KNOW THAT IF YOU TALK TO YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES, THAT'S A BIG
DEAL. SPECIFICALLY, SACRAMENTO
COG FELL SHORT BY 2484 UNIT
HOUSING UNITS AND SANTA BARBARA
COG BY 1338 UNITS. ADDITIONALLY,
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT HCD
COULD NOT DEMONSTRATE THAT IT
HAD ADEQUATELY CONSIDERED ALL
FACTORS AS REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW. IN RESPONSE, A STATE
AUDITOR REPORTED THESE
SHORTCOMINGS RISKED ERODING
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN HCD'S
ABILITY TO PROVIDE ACCURATE
INFORMATION TO COGS CONCERNING
HOUSING NEEDS. THE STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED A FORMAL REVIEW
PROCESS AND THOROUGH
DOCUMENTATION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
ARENA CALCULATIONS PROVIDED TO
COGS ARE ACCURATE. ADDITIONALLY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO IS
COMMITTED TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
HCD AND THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE
IMPROVED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CURRENT
SEVENTH ARENA CYCLE. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
KEVIN. KEVIN GILHOOLY,
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS. SKAG AND SABRINA
BRADBURY, DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCILS OF
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT. CAL COG.
OKAY. THANK YOU. WELCOME. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS NOT
TO LOWER OR TO INCREASE THE
ARENA OF DETERMINATION, BUT TO
ENSURE ITS ACCURACY AS AN
AGENCY, SCAG TAKES OUR ROLE VERY
SERIOUSLY TO HELP SOLVE FOR THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS, WHICH IS
WHY SCAG ADVOCATED VERY HEAVILY
FOR CRITICAL HOUSING PROGRAMS
THIS BUDGET CYCLE, INCLUDING THE
REAP 2.0 PROGRAM, WHICH WILL
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
66,000 HOUSING UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION.
GIVEN HOW CRUCIAL THE ARENA
DETERMINATION IS FOR OUR CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO PLAN FOR THEIR
SHARE OF THE REGION'S HOUSING
NEED, IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THESE NUMBERS BE ACCURATE AND
THE JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
ASSIGNED THESE NUMBERS BE
CONFIDENT IN THAT ACCURACY. IN
2022, THE STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCTED THE REPORT THAT THE
SENATOR MENTIONED AND FOUND THAT
SOME OF THE ARENA DETERMINATIONS
IN THE STATE WERE INACCURATE. IN
FACT, THEY WERE UNDERCOUNTED.
ADDITIONALLY, IN THE SCAG
REGION, WITH OUR 1.34 MILLION
ARENA DETERMINATION, MANY OF OUR
MEMBER CITIES AND COUNTIES
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION WITH THE
PERCEIVED LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
SURROUNDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR REGIONS. FINAL DETERMINATION
AB 2485 SEEKS TO ADDRESS THESE.
THESE CONCERNS. DEMOGRAPHIC
EXPERTS WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE
PROCESS, INCLUDING A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE US
CENSUS BUREAU AND OTHER EXPERTS
IN THE DATA, SUCH AS AN
ACADEMICIAN WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS PEER REVIEW THAT'S
NEEDED TO THIS PROCESS. DURING
THE SIXTH CYCLE, RINA SCAGGS,
RINA APPEALS BOARD REVIEWED 52
APPEALS FROM OUR CITIES TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL ARENA NUMBERS. MANY
OF THESE CITIES RAISED THE LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY OF THE WITHIN
THE REGIONAL DETERMINATION
PROCESS DURING THEIR INDIVIDUAL
APPEAL. EACH APPEAL TOOK SCAG AN
HOUR TO ADJUDICATE, WHICH WAS
TIME THAT WAS NOT SPENT ON
UPDATING OUR HOUSING ELEMENTS OR
ENGAGING COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT PROCESS.
OUR HOPE IS THAT BY INCREASING
THE TRUST IN THE PROCESS ON THE
FRONT END THROUGH ADDED
TRANSPARENCY, THERE WILL BE
FEWER APPEALS AND FEWER DELAYS
SO THAT JURISDICTIONS CAN BEGIN
THE IMPORTANT WORK OF UPDATING
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS ON THE
BACK END TO ADEQUATELY PLAN FOR
THE DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING
THAT OUR REGION NEEDS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SABRINA BRADBURY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS AND I
WILL BE BRIEF IN JUST ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE KEVIN'S COMMENTS, BUT
FROM A STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE, WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
FURTHER STRENGTHEN THE INTEGRITY
OF THE RINA PROCESS BY ASSURING
THAT DATA SOURCES AND ANALYZES
AND METHODOLOGIES USED TO
DEVELOP THE REGIONAL
DETERMINATION IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES TO
COMMENT ON. THIS IS MUCH LIKE A
PROCESS THAT A COG MUST HOLD
WHEN THEY DO THEIR ARENA FOR
THEIR WITHIN THEIR REGION, AND
THIS TRANSPARENCY WILL INCREASE
TRUST IN THAT RINA PROCESS.
STATEWIDE THE SECOND REASON THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL IS
THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH THE RINA PROCESS
IS THAT THOSE THAT MUST
IMPLEMENT IT DO NOT ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND THE BASIS FOR THE
NUMBERS. AS A RESULT, IT IS
OFTEN PANNED AS A MERE STATE
MANDATE, EVEN BY THOSE WHO
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY. SO A PROCESS
THAT CONNECTS THE HOUSING
DETERMINATION TO THE STATE GOAL
IN AN EVIDENCE BASED WAY WILL
LEAD TO A BETTER AND QUICKER
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB
2485 HERE IN ROOM 1200. NICOLE
WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY
GUERIN, ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR RUSSELL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CORONADO
AND THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON. MARTHA
GUERRERO, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. JEFF
NEILL, REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
OF IMPERIAL. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, WE WILL
NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2485, SEEING
NONE, WE WILL NOW BRING YOU BACK
TO THE DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS BY OUR MEMBERS. WE HAVE
A IS THAT OKAY? WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR CORTEZ. SENATOR
CABRERA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MA'AM.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER, A CHOBOQ A
CHOBOQ. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. BLAKE.
SPEER, I CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
MENGIBAR. PADILLA. CIERTO.
UMBRAL. WAHAB THAT'S 4 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS. RIGHT, WE
COULD TAKE A MOTION ON.
SEVEN. FINAL ITEM. NUMBER EIGHT
AB 2729 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR. SENATOR
SKINNER, A TRO BO AYE A TROBOK
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR
PADILLA. SERRATO. UMBERG AND
WAHAB. 2 TO 0. PADILLA I
CABALLERO. AYE 4 TO 2. 4 TO 0.
SORRY.
WE WILL BE TAKING A BRIEF RECESS
UNTIL WE BRING OR WE HAVE SOME
AUTHORS ARRIVE.
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR Þ.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL FOR
OUR CONSENT ITEMS. ON THE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
UMBERG. WAHAB AS 8 TO 0. OKAY.
WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OKAY. WE'LL BE REOPENING THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. YOU'RE
STRESSING MY FRIEND OUT HERE. NO
GOOD. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 0 WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE, SENATOR UMBERG WAHAB
WAHHAB. AYE. 9 TO 0 9 TO 0.
WE'LL ALSO KEEP IT OPEN ONE MORE
TIME. OR MAYBE TWO.
WE WILL OPEN THE ROLL FOR AB 930
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
CIERTO. UMBERG. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. THAT IS 6 TO 1 AND WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN. PERHAPS AND
MEMBERS WILL CONTINUE WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 2553 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0 WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. SENATOR CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. MENGIBAR PADILLA
. PADILLA. AYE. SATO. UMBERG.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE THE 7 TO 0 7 TO
0. KEEP THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 2712 BY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MR. MCCARTY, DO YOU WANT TO CALL
IT REALLY QUICK? YES THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE FLOOR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
CIERTO CIERTO. NO. UMBERG. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. THAT IS 6 TO 2. FILE
ITEM THREE. AB 2712 FROM
FRIEDMAN. WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
NOW WELCOME MEMBER MCCARTY TO
1200 RIGHT HERE. WITNESSES.
MEMBER. MEMBER MCCARTY WILL BE
PRESENTING FILE ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2593. WELCOME. THANK YOU. ONE
OF THOSE AFTERNOONS. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING US TO PRESENT THIS
MEASURE. THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
AND A BIPARTISAN MEASURE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. HOOVER AND
NGUYEN JOINING ME, FOCUSING ON
ADDRESSING OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY,
WHICH IS A CRISIS IN ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES, WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM A SECOND MY WITNESS HERE
LAST YEAR, OUR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
GRAND JURY DID A REPORT ON THIS
ISSUE, AND THEY RECOGNIZED THE
LACK OF COOPERATION AMONG
REGIONAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
SO MANY OF YOU CAME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, I'M SURE. AND YOU
SERVED ON JPAS ON LIBRARY AND
WASTEWATER AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS, EVEN CABLE
TV COMMISSION WE HAVE HERE, BUT
NOT WORKING TOGETHER ON THE
ISSUE OF THE DAY. AND, YOU KNOW,
IN OUR ON OUR STATE BUDGET
PROCESS, WE PUT MORE MONEY ON
THE TABLE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO TACKLE HOMELESSNESS. AND ONE
THING WE WANT MORE IS MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND MORE
COOPERATION AMONG LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO OUR POINT IN
TIME COUNT SHOWS THAT OUR
HOMELESSNESS IN SACRAMENTO IS
STILL A MAJOR PROBLEM. WE HAD A
SLIGHT DIP THE LAST TWO YEARS,
BUT STILL WAY TOO MANY PEOPLE
SLEEPING OUTDOORS. AS MANY OF
YOU SEE, STAYING UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY, THIS WOULD BE
PERMISSIBLE OPTION OPTIONAL. OPT
IN JPA WITH THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO AND CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO TO WORK
TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH A
REGIONAL PLAN, TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. BECAUSE THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND ONE JURISDICTION
CANNOT SOLVE IT ON THEIR OWN.
WITH ME TODAY IS MR. BILL MINER,
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GRAND JURY AND
A COAUTHOR OF THE REPORT ON THIS
TOPIC. THANK YOU. HELLO, SIR.
AND WELCOME. THANK YOU, I'M
ACTUALLY NOT A I SHOULDN'T SAY
I'M A COAUTHOR. WE EVERYTHING
THE GRAND JURY DOES TOGETHER.
SO, I WANTED TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES AND TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROCESS THAT WE WENT
THROUGH, BECAUSE WE CONDUCTED A
NUMBER OF INTERVIEWS, ALMOST TWO
DOZEN, MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY,
WHETHER THEY WERE THERE, WERE
THE CITY GOVERNMENT, COUNTY
GOVERNMENT, THE CITIES WE
INTERVIEWED, AND THEN SOME OF
THE PROVIDERS FOR SERVICES. WHAT
WE FOUND WAS THEY REALLY WORKED.
NO MATTER WHAT THEY WOULD WANT
TO COMMUNICATE IN SILOS. THEY
DID NOT WORK TOGETHER. SO WE END
UP WITH A, WE STARTED TO LOOK AT
IT MORE STRUCTURALLY THAN INTO
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS OR THINGS
YOU COULD DO TO TRY TO IMPROVE
MENTAL HEALTH OR OTHER PARTS OF
THEIR SERVICES. SO WHAT WE DID,
WE STARTED, WE TOOK A LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING ON AND IS WORKING.
SO WE DID A LOT OF WORK AROUND
OTHER COUNTIES AND WHAT COUNTIES
WERE HAVING SUCCESS IN
ADDRESSING THE HOMELESS PROBLEM.
AND WE FOUND QUITE A FEW. AND
THE COMMON THREAD WAS THEY HAD A
JPA. SO IF YOU GO TO THE REPORT,
I WANT TO CITE THE DATA. BUT
THEN WE LOOKED AT A HALF A DOZEN
AND THEY ALL HAD FLAT OR
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
THEIR PERFORMANCE WITH THE USE
OF A JPA IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY,
THEY SPEND $300 MILLION PLUS ON
THE HOMELESS PROBLEM. AND IT'S
NOT GETTING BETTER AS I POINTED
OUT, EVEN IN THE MOST RECENT
POINT IN COUNT, POINT IN TIME
COUNT, THE ISSUE IS, IS THAT
THERE IS NO ONE ACCOUNTABLE. I'M
A CITIZEN OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
I'D LIKE TO FIND OUT WHO I COULD
GO EITHER VOTE FOR OR SUPPORT
THAT COULD START TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM, BECAUSE IT'S ONLY
GETTING WORSE. IT'S NOT GETTING
BETTER. AND SO IT'S THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S MISSING.
SO I COME FROM THE CORPORATE
ENVIRONMENT. SO I USED I'M NOT
USED TO THE GOVERNMENT. THIS IS
A VERY LONG PROCESS. TODAY I BUT
WE LOOK STRUCTURALLY AT PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE ASSIGNED
DELIVERABLES AND GETTING IT
DONE. AND I THIS PROBLEM IS SO
BAD IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY. IT
NEEDS A MAJOR STRUCTURAL RESHIFT
WHICH IS WHY OUR GRAND JURY
RECOMMENDED THE JPA TWO
SERVICES. BEFORE THAT, THEY
RECOMMENDED JPA. SO THIS IS A
VERY COMMON PROBLEM AND IT'S
WORKING IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
SO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
NOPE. OKAY. WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM 12 1200 FOR ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2593. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES, IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS, SENATOR
BREAKSPEAR? YES THANK YOU, I
JUST WANT TO AGREE WITH THE
TESTIMONY THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
REALLY A BIG, MASSIVE PROBLEM IN
THIS STATE AND PARTICULARLY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. IT HAS REALLY
STRIKES ME THAT WE ALL COME INTO
SACRAMENTO FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE, AND WE SEE SO MANY PEOPLE
LIVING UNHOUSED ON OUR STREETS,
AND YET WE STILL SEEM TO BE
UNABLE TO REALLY GET ON TOP OF
THIS CRISIS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
CITY AND IN THIS STATE. SO I
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP IN
THINKING ABOUT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO, YOUR HOMETOWN, AND A
PLACE WHERE YOU MAY BE THE
LEADER OF AS WELL, AND THINKING
ABOUT STRUCTURAL CHANGE AND
MAYBE A JPA, IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD REALLY BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. I, DON'T PROFESS TO
REALLY KNOW THE INS AND OUTS OF
IT, BUT SINCE THE BILL, IS
REALLY JUST AUTHORIZING THE
COUNTY TO CREATE A JPA, IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S CERTAINLY NO HARM
IN TRYING THAT. AND I AGREE THAT
JPAS HAVE BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT
SOLVING OTHER PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HAD. AND, AND GETTING
PEOPLE DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY TO
THAT. SO WHEN THE TIME COMES,
I'M HAPPY TO MAKE A MOTION FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BLAKE. SPIRIT DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS, I GUESS I WILL JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION OR JUST A
COMMENT. ACTUALLY, IT'S A
QUESTION. HOW WOULD YOU, RESPOND
TO, THE NOTION THAT CITIES CAN
ALREADY CREATE JPAS AND, THE
COUNTY COULD ALSO AS WELL DO IT.
WHY THE MEASURE THROUGH THE
STATE LEGISLATURE? YEAH. FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE IT TO PUT IT TO PUT
IT IN STATUTE, MANY OF OUR LOCAL
JPAS ARE CREATED IN STATUTE AS
WELL. SOME OF THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY JPAS. AND THIS IS 100%
OPTIONAL. AND SOME OF THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES AT THE BEGINNING
SAID, DON'T TAKE AWAY OUR LAND
USE AUTHORITY. SO WE'RE NOT
TOUCHING THAT. DON'T TAKE AWAY
OUR ABILITY TO SPEND OUR OWN
MONEY. WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING
THAT, THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ONE VOTE PER CITY SO
THEY CAN HAVE THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO LIKE STACKING THEIR
VOTES AGAINST THE SMALLER CITY.
AND SO WE HAVE ONE VOTE PER
JURISDICTION. SO WE'VE WORKED ON
ALL OF THESE ISSUES, AND THEY
DIDN'T, SOME OF THE
JURISDICTIONS SAID, OF COURSE,
THAT THEY COULD OPT INTO IT IF
THEY CHOOSE TO. AND SO WE HAVE
100% PERMISSIBLE. AND SO WE
THINK THIS WOULD CREATE MORE
WEIGHT. I THINK THIS COULD BE A
MODEL FOR OTHER COUNTIES ACROSS,
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND, AND WHEN
WE NOTICE EVERY YEAR IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND WE'RE ALL
PART OF THIS IS WE LOOK AT HOW
MUCH MONEY WE'RE SPENDING AND WE
SCRATCH OUR HEADS AND WE'RE
LIKE, ARE WE GETTING THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK? AND THIS IS
PROBABLY NØ. SO MORE COOPERATION
IS A BETTER THING. AND I THINK
THIS HELPS FOSTER JUST THAT.
WITH THAT, I'LL USE IT AS MY
CLOSE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS,
OKAY. SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATOR SKINNER.
OKOBOJI. AYE OKOBOJI. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. CORTESI. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. CARILLO AYE. SERRATTO. AYE.
UMBERG. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE
CONGRATULATIONS, MEMBER
MCCARTNEY. WE WILL KEEP THAT
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CONGRATULATIONS OH, OKAY. WE
HAVE MEMBER CARILLO. SHE WILL BE
PRESENTING FILE ITEM NUMBER 18,
AB 3177. WELCOME.
WHEN YOU'RE READY, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 3177, WHICH
ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES ON SPOT
WIDENING, A PRACTICE IN WHICH
DEVELOPERS CEDE A PORTION OF
THEIR LAND ADJACENT TO THE
ROADWAY TO WIDEN IT WITHOUT ANY
COMPENSATION. THIS PRACTICE IS
DONE IN A HANDFUL OF
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, OFTEN RESULTING IN
ROADS THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY
ZIGZAGGING PARCEL BY PARCEL,
FAILING TO MEET THE INTENDED
PURPOSE OF TRAFFIC MITIGATION,
AND FREQUENTLY INDUCE FASTER AND
ACTUALLY MORE DANGEROUS DRIVING.
SPOT WIDENING REQUIREMENTS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE HOUSING
COSTS, ADDING BETWEEN 10,000 TO
$50,000 PER HOUSING UNIT,
AMOUNTING TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS PER PROJECT. THIS
ADDITIONALLY COSTS. THIS
ADDITIONAL COST TRANSLATES
DIRECTLY INTO HIGHER RENTS,
UNDERCUTTING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. MOREOVER, THESE
REQUIREMENTS REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF LAND AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING,
DECREASING THE NUMBER OF
FEASIBLE UNITS ON A PROPERTY.
LIKEWISE, THE DEMANDS IMPOSED BY
SPOT WIDENING CAN MAKE MANY
POTENTIAL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
INFEASIBLE, AS WAS THE CASE WITH
THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES THAT
FOUGHT FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS TO
RECEIVE A WAIVER. THIS BILL
LIMITS THE PRACTICE OF SPOT
WIDENING BY PROHIBITING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM IMPOSING A LAND
DEDICATED REQUIREMENT FOR
ROADWAY WIDENING ON A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN A TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREA, OR FOR
DEVELOPMENTS WITH STREET
FRONTAGE OF LESS THAN 500FT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAY STILL IMPOSE A
LAND DEDICATION REQUIREMENT ON
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS FOR TRAFFIC
SAFETY FEATURES. IF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES A FINDING
SPECIFIC TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, SUPPORTED BY
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THE
LAND DEDICATION REQUIREMENT IS
NECESSARY TO PRESERVE THE HEALTH
, SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE
PUBLIC, SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE IS
THE LOWEST STANDARD AVAILABLE AS
SUCH, THIS PROVISION WILL
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
FLEXIBILITY WHERE NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY AB 3177 REPLACES
THE REFERENCE TO TRANSIT STATION
WITH TRANSIT PRIORITY AREA
WITHIN THE MITIGATION FEE ACT,
PROVIDING REDUCED MITIGATION
FEES FOR HOUSING NEAR BUS STOPS
AND PLANNED TRANSIT STOPS WITHIN
ONE YEAR OF COMPLETION, WHICH
THE LIMITED DEFINITION OF
TRANSIT STATION THAT IS NOT USED
ELSEWHERE IN STATE LAW DOES NOT
COVER THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL, ARE WELL ALIGNED WITH THE
STATE'S GOALS TO INCENTIVIZE NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND CLIMATE
SMART PLACES. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY STREETS FOR ALL AND
SUPPORTED BY A COALITION OF
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ADVOCATE FOR BOTH MARKET RATE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AS WELL
AS ENVIRONMENTAL AND STREET
SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS. MOREOVER,
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 31. 77
IS KRISTIN BLAD, ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY, AND
MARK VUKOVICH, DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY FOR STREETS FOR ALL. AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MAYOR CARILLO.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
AND WELCOME. THANK YOU, MY NAME
IS KIRSTEN BLAD, AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY FOR STREETS FOR ALL. THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. OUR
BILL ENDS THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING A HOUSING DEVELOPER TO
GIVE UP POTENTIAL HOUSING, LAND
AND PAY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
WIDENING A PORTION OF THE ROAD
AS A CONDITION OF APPROVAL FOR
ENTITLEMENTS, A PRACTICE KNOWN
AS SPOT WIDENING. SPOT WIDENING
IS BASED ON THE ANTIQUATED AND
DISPROVEN IDEA THAT WE CAN WIDEN
OUR WAY OUT OF TRAFFIC
CONGESTION ON A PARCEL BY PARCEL
BASIS THROUGH THIS FUTILE
ATTEMPT TO REDUCE CONGESTION, WE
ARE MAKING OUR STREETS MORE
DANGEROUS AND OUR CITIES LESS
LIVABLE. EVEN SACRIFICING THE
WIDTH OF THE SIDEWALK. IN SOME
OF THESE CASES, SPOT WIDENING
TYPICALLY ACHIEVES NOTHING MORE
THAN AN INCREASED WIDTH OF
EXISTING TRAVEL LANES FOR A VERY
SHORT DISTANCE, WHICH DOES
NOTHING TO MITIGATE CONGESTION
BUT DOES HAVE THE EFFECT OF
FACILITATING COLLISIONS. I WANT
TO ALSO SHARE WHAT THIS IS LIKE
ON THE HOUSING SIDE. ONE PROJECT
IN LÀ LOST OVER 6000FT² OF LAND
TO THESE ROAD WIDENINGS, WHICH
MEANS THEY LOST THE ABILITY TO
BUILD OVER 30 DWELLING UNITS.
ANOTHER PROJECT, CONSISTING OF
100% SUPPORTIVE HOMELESS HOUSING
BY A NONPROFIT DEVELOPER, WAS
DELAYED FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS
AFTER THEY HAD TO APPEAL THIS
REQUIREMENT, AS THEIR PROJECT
WOULD NOT PENCIL OTHERWISE. IN
THE TIME IT TOOK FOR THAT
DEVELOPER TO OBTAIN A WAIVER, AN
ADDITIONAL 12,000 PEOPLE FELL
INTO HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
SO, IN SUM, GOOD GOVERNANCE
FOLKS SUPPORT OUR BILL BECAUSE
OUR GROWING PAVEMENT MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG IS BANKRUPTING RURAL AND
SUBURBAN CITIES.
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE SPOT WIDENING RIPS
UP MATURE TREES, INDUCES MORE
CAR TRIPS AND WORSENS THE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT. MARKET RATE
AND AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE THIS POLICY
MAKES THEIR PROJECTS CHEAPER TO
FINANCE AND PENCIL. AND LASTLY,
SAFE STREETS GROUPS LIKE US ARE
THE SPONSORS BECAUSE THIS SORT
OF WIDENING JUST INDUCES
DANGEROUS SPEEDING THROUGH WIDER
LANES NEXT TO BRAND NEW HOUSING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YES
VOTE. WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MARK
VUKOVICH, BUT I'M ACTUALLY
READING A WRITTEN STATEMENT
PREPARED BY PROFESSOR MICHAEL
MANVILLE, CHAIR OF THE UCLA
URBAN PLANNING DEPARTMENT, AND
HIS TESTIMONY IS BASED ON SOME
OF THE MATERIALS THAT WE HANDED
TO THE SERGEANTS. I'M A
PROFESSOR OF URBAN PLANNING AT
UCLA, CHAIR OF OUR UCLA URBAN
PLANNING DEPARTMENT. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. I HAVE STUDIED THE
ORIGINS AND OUTCOMES OF THIS LAW
THAT THIS BILL TARGETS, AND I'M
THE AUTHOR OF THE RESEARCH PAPER
THAT'S BEING DISTRIBUTED TO
LEGISLATORS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATOR, ABOUT THIS LAW, AND
SOME OF THE MOST UNUSUAL AND
LEAST EFFICIENT REGULATIONS I
HAVE EVER ENCOUNTERED. I WILL
MAKE FIRST THREE POINTS. FIRST,
THESE RULES HAVE VERY FEW
BENEFITS. THEIR NOMINAL GOAL IS
TO REDUCE CONGESTION. THEY DON'T
IN MANY INSTANCES. IN FACT, THEY
EXACERBATE CONGESTION BY
CREATING BOTTLENECKS IRREGULAR
STREET ALIGNMENTS. SECOND, THESE
RULES HAVE REAL COSTS THAT
EXACERBATE THE HOUSING CRISIS.
BECAUSE THESE WIDENINGS REMOVE
LAND THAT COULD BE USED FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND THEY
IMPOSE BOTH MONETARY COSTS, TIME
DELAYS AND UNCERTAINTY ON
DEVELOPERS. THIRD, THESE LAWS,
ONCE PUT IN PLACE, TAKE ON A
LIFE OF THEIR OWN AND BECOME
VERY DIFFICULT TO REFORM OR
REMOVE. AND I'LL ELABORATE ON
EACH POINT. THE NOMINAL GOALS OF
THESE LAWS IS TO REDUCE
CONGESTION BY WIDENING THE
STREETS AND DECADES OF RESEARCH
OVERWHELMINGLY SAYS THAT THIS
WON'T WORK BECAUSE WIDER STREETS
DON'T MAKE VEHICLES MOVE ANY
FASTER AT PEAK HOURS. BUT THAT'S
NOT EVEN THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
RULE. THE PROBLEM IS THAT YOU
ACTUALLY NEVER GET A WIDER
STREET BECAUSE YOU NEVER WIDEN
THE WHOLE STREET. YOU DO WIDEN
IT PIECEMEAL. ONE INCREMENTAL
PARCEL AT A TIME. AS A RESULT,
THE LAW ACTUALLY CREATES
BOTTLENECKS BY INTRODUCING
IRREGULAR STREET PATTERNS WHERE
THE STREET GETS WIDER AND
NARROWER FROM ONE BLOCK TO THE
NEXT. THIS SNARLS TRAFFIC AND IT
CREATES SAFETY PROBLEMS AND
MAKES DRAINAGE PROBLEMS AND
MAINTENANCE MORE DIFFICULT.
SECOND POINT EVEN THOUGH ADDING
ROAD SPACE INCREMENTALLY DOESN'T
REDUCE CONGESTION, TAKING IT
INCREMENTALLY DOES. ADD DOES
INHIBIT AFFORDABILITY AND THAT
IS THE CASE, THAT IS THE CASE
BECAUSE THE INCREMENTAL IS
OFTENTIMES IMPORTANT TO THE
FEASIBILITY OF MARKET RATE OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AT BEST, THE COST OF REQUIRED
WIDENING MAKE IT SO THAT THE
DEVELOPER CANNOT BUILD AS MANY
UNITS AS THEY WOULD PREFER, AND
AT WORST, IT MAKES THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF A PARCEL
COMPLETELY IMPOSSIBLE. AND WHEN
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE, NOT ONLY DO
YOU LOSE NOT DO YOU, NOT ONLY DO
YOU LOSE HOUSING, BUT YOU ALSO
INTEND. EXCUSE ME, YOU ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LAW IS NEVER GOING
TO ACTUALLY DO WHAT IT'S
INTENDED TO DO, WHICH IS WIDEN
THE ROADWAY, BECAUSE THE
WIDENING CAN ONLY HAPPEN IF A
PARCEL IS REDEVELOPED. THIRD
POINT IF IT'S FAIR TO ASK WHY
THIS LAW DOESN'T WORK VERY WELL
AND WHY WE NEED STATE
INTERVENTION, AND WHY SHOULD WHY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN'T JUST
STOP ENGAGING THIS IN
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE BEHAVIOR ON
OUR OWN? I ACTUALLY HAVE NO
DEFINITIVE ANSWER FOR THAT, BUT
I CAN SAY THAT MY EXPERIENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THEY CAN'T. LOS
ANGELES HAS A LAW OF THIS SORT
FOR 60 YEARS, AND VERY FEW
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S FUNCTIONAL
OR WORTHWHILE. MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH THIS A
LOT SUGGEST THAT OVER TIME, IT
HAS BECOME LIKE A PLANE QUIETLY
FLYING OVER ON AUTOPILOT. IT'S
BURIED IN THE HOUSING APPROVAL
PROCESS. AUTHORITIES DISPERSED
OVER MULTIPLE AGENCIES. IF YOU
TALK TO PEOPLE IN THOSE
AGENCIES, THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT'S A PROBLEM, BUT NONE OF THEM
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE EMPOWERED TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM. AND SO WHAT
WE NOW HAVE IS A SITUATION WHERE
A SITUATION WHERE THIS PROBLEM
WAS MADE QUITE A LONG TIME AGO,
CREATING A DILEMMA FOR LOCAL
OFFICIALS TODAY. AND THEY DON'T
FEEL LIKE THEY CAN SOLVE IT. SO
THEY'RE PUSHING THAT DILEMMA
FORWARD TO OFFICIALS IN THE
FUTURE, WHICH IS THE CORE OF THE
PROBLEM FOR THIS BILL. I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ATTENTION
SIGNED. PROFESSOR MICHAEL
MANVILLE, PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF
THE URBAN PLANNING DEPARTMENT AT
UCLA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM 1200.
STEPHEN SANDLER WITH BROWNSTEIN
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION AND SUPPORT. AND MARK
STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. RAFA SONNENFELD WITH
THE EMB ACTION AND SUPPORT.
BROOKE PRITCHETT, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM 1200 WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH ANY LEAD OPPOSITION FOR AB
31 1777. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. SENATOR BLAKESPEAR. YES.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL, AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE READ BY FROM
THE PROFESSOR, BUT I JUST I KNOW
THIS IS NOT THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. THIS IS THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. AND I'M ALSO ON
TRANSPORTATION. SO MAYBE I
SHOULD JUST HOLD MY QUESTION,
BUT I'M BURNING TO ASK IT. WHICH
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID IN THE
LETTER? WHAT YOU READ FROM THE
LETTER IS THAT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
WORKING, LIKE THE STREET WILL
NEVER END UP ACTUALLY BEING
WIDER. IT CREATES BOTTLENECKS.
INSTEAD OF CREATING MORE WIDTH.
BUT FROM THE CITY THAT THAT I
CAME FROM, WE DID THIS AS PART
OF LIKE THE BICYCLE LANE AND
SIDEWALK NETWORK. SO WHENEVER A
HOUSE WAS REDEVELOPED ALONG A
RESIDENTIAL STREET, THEN THEY
WOULD HAVE TO DEDICATE SO THAT
THERE WOULD EVENTUALLY BE A
SIDEWALK IT SINCE IN THE AMOUNT
OF TIME I WAS INVOLVED, WHICH
ADMITTEDLY WAS NOT DECADES, BUT
WE NEVER REALLY CREATED
CONTINUOUS SIDEWALKS. BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY PART OF THE CITY
PROCESS TO TRY TO CREATE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS THROUGH
THIS INCREMENTAL DEVELOPMENT. SO
JUST CONCEPTUALLY, I'M WONDERING
IF THIS APPLIES TO BIKE LANES
AND PEDESTRIAN PATHS IN THE SAME
WAY IT DOES TO TRAVEL LANES
WHERE IT'S BASICALLY CONSIDERED
POTENTIALLY BAD POLICY. AND I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHO IN THE
THREE OF YOU WOULD BE BEST, BUT
I'M INTERESTED IN THE QUESTION.
IN THE ANSWER. YEAH, I CAN
ANSWER THAT, SO THE BILL DOES
PROVIDE CITIES WITH THE ABILITY
TO MAKE A FINDING. FOR SAFETY
PROJECTS, WHICH WHICH BIKE LANES
WOULD FALL UNDER OR PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY PROJECTS OR EVEN JUST
GENERAL TRAFFIC SAFETY PROJECTS,
BUT YEAH, WE DO FIND THAT
ESPECIALLY, AS THIS IS PRACTICED
IN LA, AT LEAST, WHICH I HAVE
MOST EXPERIENCE WITH, THAT IT
VERY RARELY LEADS TO THE ENTIRE
BLOCK BEING WIDENED. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A PROVISION IN THIS BILL
THAT IF SOMEONE IS DEVELOPING
THE ENTIRE BLOCK, THAT THAT THEY
COULD STILL REQUIRE TO BE
WIDENED BECAUSE THAT JUST MAKES
MORE SENSE. I'LL ALSO NOTE THAT
SIDEWALKS ARE SPECIFICALLY
EXEMPTED FROM OUR BILL, SO THIS
THIS STILL CAN BE PUT IN A
REQUIREMENT FOR, FOR DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE SAKE OF A SIDEWALK, AND
SORRY, THERE WAS ANOTHER THING.
I'LL JUST ADD ONE MORE THING.
YEAH. SO IT'S ONLY APPLYING TO
THE ROADWAY, WHICH IS THE CURB
TO CURB. SO THE RIGHT OF WAY YOU
COULD STILL HAVE A DEDICATION
FOR. SO IF YOU WANT TO REQUIRE A
DEDICATION FOR LANDSCAPING OR
WIDER SIDEWALKS OR EVEN CLASS
FOR BIKE LANES THAT ARE NOT IN
THE ROADWAY, THAT ARE ACTUALLY
LIKE AN EXTENSION OF THE
SIDEWALK, YOU COULD STILL DO
THAT AS WELL. THE LAST THING
I'LL ADD, WHICH IS, THAT THE
FACT THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
PIECEMEAL. SO YOU THINK ABOUT
YOU THINK ABOUT A STREET
FRONTAGE, YOU THINK ABOUT ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT PARCELS THAT ARE
ON IT, ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
HOUSES THAT ARE ON IT. AND THIS
IS JUST ONE SINGLE REDEVELOPMENT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY BUILD A
BIKE LANE. AND WHEN IT DOES AND
WHEN THIS REQUIREMENT, AT LEAST
IN THE CITIES THAT WE'VE LOOKED
AT, ARE PUT FOR THE SAKE OF A
BIKE LANE, OFTEN OFTENTIMES THAT
BIKE LANE IS ACTUALLY NEVER PUT
IN. IT'S THE REQUIREMENT IS PUT,
BUT THE BIKE LANE IS NEVER
ACTUALLY STRIPED. AND SO THAT'S
THE OTHER CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACED, AT LEAST WITHIN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND A FEW OTHER
DEVELOPMENTS, BUT ULTIMATELY, WE
THINK THAT THE BILL AS A STREET
SAFETY GROUP, WE THINK THAT THE
BILL BALANCES THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND THE
BIKE AND WALK NEEDS, FAIRLY WELL
BECAUSE THE FUNDING REQUIREMENT
AND THE SIDEWALK EXEMPTION THAT
WE SPECIFICALLY PUT. OKAY. YEAH,
I DID NOTICE THE EXEMPTION FOR
SIDEWALKS AND SEWER
IMPROVEMENTS. I MEAN, I DO I
STILL HAVE THAT QUESTION ABOUT
OTHER ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
THINGS, BUT I'LL YOU KNOW, I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT. BUT IT DOES
CONCERN ME A LITTLE BIT. BUT
YEAH, I GET IT ON THE CARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
SIERRA, THANK YOU. OKAY. SO I
HATE THOSE LITTLE IN AND OUT
THINGS TO UNFORTUNATELY, I'VE
GROWN TO UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
EXIST AND THE CHANGES IN TAX
LAWS AND THINGS LIKE THAT, AND
WHERE WE CAN GET MONEY AND, AND
HOW YOU CAN COLLECT MONEY AND,
AND ALL OF THIS RELATED TO
DEVELOPMENT. MY CONCERN IS,
LET'S SAY WE DO IT YOUR GUYS WAY
AND WE TELL THE DEVELOPER, YEAH,
YOU CAN YOU CAN BUILD HOUSING ON
THAT. IF THE STREET IS SOMEDAY
SUPPOSED TO BE FOUR LANES WIDE
AND YOU'VE BUILT HOUSING ALL THE
WAY UP TO THE ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE SIDEWALK, AND NOW YOU NEED
SPACE FOR ADDITIONAL LANES
BECAUSE THIS, THIS HAPPENS IN
NEWER CITIES. AND THAT'S WHY
SOMETIMES LÀ SOLUTIONS DON'T FIT
FOR OTHER CITIES, THEN THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO TAKE OUT
HOUSING TO BE ABLE TO, TO, TO
WIDEN THE ROAD TO HANDLE THE
TRAFFIC. OTHERWISE THE HOUSING
IS THERE IS GOING TO BE SITTING
THERE LOOKING AT A TRAFFIC JAM
ALL DAY LONG, SO IT'S, IT'S, YOU
KNOW, THE REASON THEY DO THAT IS
THE DEVELOPERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR EITHER DEDICATING THE LAND
THAT WILL EVENTUALLY CAUSE THAT
LAND IN FRONT OF THEIR PROPERTY
IS GOING TO BE NOTHING BUT A
ROAD, STREET, BIKE LANE OR
WHATEVER IT IS THEY HAVE
PLANNED. SOMEDAY, IF YOU DO AWAY
WITH THAT, THEN IT WON'T EVER BE
THAT, AND YOU'LL BE STUCK WITH
ROADS THAT YOU CAN'T WIDEN PALO
ALTO ANYWAY, WHERE YOU HAVE
NOWHERE ELSE TO WIDEN A ROAD.
AND SO YOU HAVE ALL THIS TRAFFIC
IN NEIGHBORHOODS AND NOT
ARTERIALS. WELL, ARTERIALS ALSO,
BUT THE OTHER STREET
INFRASTRUCTURE FEEDER LINE, OUR
FEEDER INDUSTRY INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR STREETS THAT GO INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY SIZED. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE PLANNING PART OF CITIES
IS ALL ABOUT, IS PLANNING THEIR
STREETS TO BE WIDE ENOUGH
SOMEDAY TO HANDLE THE TRAFFIC
THAT'S COMING IN WITH THE
HOUSING THAT'S COMING IN. IT ALL
KIND OF FITS TOGETHER. AND THE
REASON THAT DEVELOPERS CHOOSE TO
GO AHEAD AND DO THE IMPROVEMENT
IS BECAUSE THEY CAN DO IT
CHEAPER THAN WHAT THE MITIGATION
FEE IS GOING TO BE IF THEY'RE
PUTTING INTO THE POT, BECAUSE
WHEN THE CITY HAS TO DO IT, THEY
HAVE TO DO IT TO THOSE THOSE
LABOR STANDARDS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE. THE DEVELOPER THAT'S GOING
IN CAN GET THEIR PEOPLE TO PUT
IN THE ROAD, AND IT'S CHEAPER
FOR THEM THAT WAY. SO THAT'S WHY
WE WIND UP HAVING THESE, BECAUSE
UNLESS EVERY SINGLE PARCEL ALONG
THAT STRETCH OF ROAD GOES IN,
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO HAVE A
FULL STREET UNTIL THE CITY
SOMEDAY SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THERE'S ONLY TWO MORE PARCELS
THAT NEED IT. THEY MAKE A DEAL
WITH THOSE FOLKS, TELL THEM
WE'LL PUT IN THE ROAD. YOU JUST
DEDICATE THE LAND, THEY DEDICATE
THE LAND. THE ROAD GETS DONE,
THAT'S HOW A LOT OF CITIES HAVE
DONE IT OVER THE YEARS. THE
NEWER DEVELOPING CITIES, THEY
NEED THIS. THEY CAN'T. IF YOU DO
THIS TO THEM, THEY WIND UP WITH
ROAD OF INADEQUATE ROAD, BIKE
LANE, INFRASTRUCTURE, SIDEWALK,
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALL OF THAT
STUFF GOES AWAY. SO THAT'S WHY,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIND A BETTER WAY OF APPLYING
THIS IN CITIES THAT NEED IT, BUT
NOT PUTTING A BLANKET OVER
CITIES THAT IT'S GOING TO HAMPER
THEIR ABILITY TO CREATE
CIRCULATION PLANS THAT ARE SAFE
FOR THEIR THEIR CITIZENRY AND
THAT FIT INTO WHAT THEIR
POPULATION IS GOING TO BE, AND
ALSO WHAT THEIR TRAFFIC PATTERNS
ARE GOING TO BE. BECAUSE A LOT
OF OUR PEOPLE ARE COMMUTERS,
THEY ALL GET IN THEIR CAR AND
THEY DRIVE 62% DRIVE OFF TO BIG
CITIES FOR THEIR JOBS. AND UNTIL
WE FIX THAT PROBLEM, IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE. SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
MOVE OUT TO OUR AREAS. THE AREAS
THAT I REPRESENT HAVE THIS ISSUE
AND THEY'RE WORKING ON IT, THERE
ARE SO LESS MANY. THERE ARE SO
FEWER OF THOSE IN MY CITY THAT I
LIVE IN NOW THAN THERE WERE TEN
YEARS AGO, BECAUSE DEVELOPMENTS
COME ALONG AND PUT THEM IN. THIS
WILL HAMPER THAT. AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SUPPORT THIS
AS A SOLUTION FOR EVERYBODY. IT
MIGHT BE A SOLUTION FOR LÀ, OR
IT MIGHT BE FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER URBAN AREAS, BUT IT'S NOT
FOR AREAS I REPRESENT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR ORTEZ. WELL, MY
INITIAL SORT OF SELFISH REACTION
WAS, WHERE WERE YOU LIKE 20
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS BUILDING
THINGS? BECAUSE THIS IS ALWAYS
BEEN A PLAGUE FOR DEVELOPERS IN
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE, COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA, AND IT DOES LEAD TO
HODGEPODGE, ROAD WIDENING IS
WHAT I WOULD CALL IT, I SUSPECT
WHAT THIS THE BIGGEST BURDEN ON
THIS WILL JUST BE THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
USE EMINENT DOMAIN IF THEY
REALLY WANT IT, I THINK PROBABLY
SENATOR CABALLERO, BECAUSE SOME
OF THE CASE LAW HAPPENED DOWN IN
HER AREA YEARS AGO, KNOWS THE
FIGHT. BUT, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD JUST PUT LINES ON MAPS ON
GENERAL PLAN MAPS AND THEN LATER
ARGUE THAT THOSE LINES
CONSTITUTED, IN EFFECT, A PRE
DEDICATION, EVEN BEFORE, YOU
KNOW, THE PROPERTY HAD CHANGED
HANDS OR, YOU KNOW, THE FIG
ORCHARD DECIDED TO BECOME
HOUSING OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE. SO I THINK THIS IS GOOD. I
THINK IT FORCES THE ISSUE BACK
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. IT SORT
OF SWINGS THE PENDULUM BACK THE
OTHER WAY AND SAYS TO THE VERY,
VERY CLEARLY TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, IF YOU WANT IT,
THEN YOU HAVE TO PAY JUST
COMPENSATION FOR IT. BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT UP FRONT, AND IF IT
REALLY ISN'T NECESSARY, THEN YOU
PROBABLY WON'T PAY FOR IT AND
LET THINGS GO. THE WAY THEY ARE.
AND I SUPPOSE FROM A COMPLETE
STREET STANDPOINT, OR AN
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION
STANDPOINT, IT, YOU KNOW, IT
PUSHES THINGS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THERE AS WELL, BUT IT
PROBABLY WILL LEAVE UNSOLVED
SOME EXISTING WEIRD SITUATIONS
OUT THERE BECAUSE EVERYBODY WILL
WILL BACK OFF AND NOBODY WILL
ACTUALLY GET IT DONE, BUT I
THINK, THAT'S KIND OF HAPPENING
ANYWAY. SO I'LL STOP THERE AND
JUST SAY I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. COULD HAVE
BEEN DONE YEARS AGO. THANK YOU.
IS THAT A MOTION THAT IS MOTION.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENATOR
CABALLERO? SO LET ME LET ME JUST
SAY THAT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE. I'M
STRUGGLING WITH. AND JUST KNOW
THAT I HAVE 70 BILLS OVER IN, IN
JUDICIARY. I GOT TO GET TO. AND
THEN WE HAD THE BILLS HERE AND
THEN ALSO IN ENERGY. SO I COULD
HAVE READ THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE
CAREFULLY, BUT I GOT THEM ALL
READ, MY STRUGGLE IS HOW THIS
RELATES. SO WE, WE USE TRAFFIC
IMPACT FEES, BUT WE HAD TO DO A
STUDY AND THE STUDY HAD TO SHOW
IF YOU BUILD OUT AS YOUR GENERAL
PLAN SAYS, HERE ARE THE
IMPROVEMENTS. AND WHEN YOU'RE
BUILDING ON OLD INFRASTRUCTURE,
IT'S USUALLY RIGHT AND LEFT HAND
TURN LANES. IT'S THAT KIND OF
IT'S NOT REDOING THE ENTIRE
STREET. YOU JUST DON'T HAVE THE
SPACE TO DO THAT. BUT WE'VE
MOVED AWAY FROM THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE MODEL, TO MY CHAGRIN,
BECAUSE I HAVE A RURAL
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE CITY OF FRESNO.
THAT'S VERY URBANIZED. AND, AND
TO USE THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED, DESIGNATION FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE WHERE YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT FOR EVERY HOUSE THAT
YOU'RE BUILDING, WHAT THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED TO, LOCAL
SERVICES WILL BE IN A REGION
WHERE THERE IS NO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, AND THE
MITIGATION MEASURES ARE BICYCLE
LANES, WALKING PATHS, THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT ARE GREAT, BUT
THEY DON'T GET PEOPLE TO WORK IN
THE MORNING AND, AND QUITE
FRANKLY, IN MY COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ISOLATED, 15,000 RESIDENTS
HALF AN HOUR FROM ANY PLACE, IT
DOESN'T WORK. AND SO THE LEVEL
OF SERVICE WORKS BETTER IN THOSE
IN THOSE AREAS THAN THE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. IT'S CREATED AN
INCREDIBLE BURDEN ON HOUSING
BECAUSE THE DEVELOPER ACTUALLY
WHAT IT'S DONE IS IT'S STOPPED
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE THE
DEVELOPER HAS A HARD TIME
FIGURING OUT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, HAS A HARD TIME
FIGURING OUT WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO CHARGE THE DEVELOPER AS A
MITIGATION IN ORDER TO GET SOME
OF THESE THINGS DONE? ANYWAY,
I'M RAMBLING, BUT MY POINT IS,
IS HOW DOES, I DON'T WANT TO GET
RID OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
USING LEVEL OF SERVICE. AND
FRANKLY, WHAT I HAVE A BILL THAT
WOULD SAY STUDY THE ISSUE AND
COME BACK WITH A WITH A
MITIGATION THAT WORKS FOR RURAL
AND SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE NO ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION OR THAT'S MINIMAL
. AND I WE'VE BUILT A STATE ON
THE NECESSITY OF USING A CAR.
AND WHILE I'M WILLING IN URBAN
AREAS TO SAY, OKAY, YOU DON'T
NEED TO HAVE AS MUCH PARKING, WE
, WE, WE'RE ALLOWING IT ANYWAY,
SO, SO HOW DOES THIS WORK WITH,
WHAT'S THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
DOING WHAT YOU'RE ASKING HERE
WITH LEVEL OF SERVICE AND THEN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED THAT THAT
MAKES THAT MAKES SENSE. I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE THE ONLY THING OFF
THE TABLE, THAT WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FIX UP THEIR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. AND HERE'S THE DEAL. IS
THAT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE FROM
THE BAY AREA ARE MOVING OUT TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD ANY TO LIVE ANY
LONGER IN THE IN THE BAY AREA.
BUT BUT THAT'S CONTRIBUTING TO
THE INCREASE IN HOUSING COSTS
FOR PEOPLE THAT DON'T EARN BAY
AREA RESOURCES. BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE AN
THAT THAT THERE BE THIS
TRANSPORTATION CONNECTIONS THAT
PROVIDE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAVE THEIR CARS BEHIND AND
SO I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE JUST I
HAVE A HARD TIME TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETIMES WHETHER
WHAT WHAT WORKS IN LÀ. AND I'M,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU SAY, OH, THIS
IS LÀ AND I'M FINE WITH IT
BECAUSE THERE ARE, THERE HAS
GROWN OR THERE. YES, THERE'S
GROWN A, A NETWORK OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THAT YOU
CAN UTILIZE. IT'S NOT GREAT, BUT
YOU CAN YOU CAN GET AROUND. BUT
FOR, FOR THE REGIONS THAT ARE
MORE ISOLATED, I'M JUST NOT SURE
THAT TAKING AWAY THIS AS AN
OPTION WORKS FOR, FOR US. SO. SO
DO YOU HAVE SOME DIRECTION
THAT'LL BE HELPFUL? I DO, I'M
GOING TO DO MY BEST THOUGH. SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST, I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE A FULLY
PRINTED OUT POWERPOINT FOR EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER WITH THE
SERGEANTS. AND I THINK THE
VISUALS HERE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO SHOW HOW SOMEWHAT ABSURD THIS
POLICY IS, BECAUSE IT'S NOT
LEADING TO BRAND NEW, BRAND NEW
STREETS ENTIRELY. AND WE HAVE
AND WE HAVE A CARVE OUT WITHIN
THE BILL. TWO THAT SAYS THAT IF
YOUR BUILDING IS 500 LINEAR
FEET, THAT'S THAT'S BASICALLY A
BLOCK. SO YOU MAY ACTUALLY BE
ADDING A NEW ROAD. YOU MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE ADDING A NEW LANE,
YOU MIGHT BE ACTUALLY ADDING NEW
CAPACITY. BUT WHEN YOU'RE DOING
THIS FOR 50FT AT A TIME ON A
ROAD THAT MIGHT BE FIVE MILES
WIDE, FIVE MILES LONG, YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE
THOSE KIND OF PURPORTED GOALS
FOR THOSE KIND OF CIRCULATION
ELEMENTS. I, I GET THAT, OKAY. I
GET WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND IT
MAKES IT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE, EXCEPT FOR THAT,
MITIGATION FEE, EXCEPT FOR THE
ADOPTED TRAFFIC LEVEL OF SERVICE
RELATED TO VEHICULAR TRAFFIC
TRAFFIC. IT'S. OH, I SEE, SO, SO
THAT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU IF, I
GUESS I GUESS I JUST SEE IT AS
TOO BROAD AS OPPOSED TO BEING
TARGETED DIRECTLY TARGETED TO
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. I GET
IT, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, THEY
THAT HAS BEEN DONE ON 99 GOING
SOUTH HORRIBLY. AND EVERY TIME
YOU SLOW DOWN AND RISK A REAR
ENDER, IT'S BECAUSE IT'S GONE
FROM THREE LANES, FROM THREE
LANES TO TWO LANES AND GO BACK
TO THREE LANES TO TWO LANES. AND
IT'S RIDICULOUS. BUT BUT, THE
WAY OUR TRAFFIC MITIGATION FEE
WORKED, YOU WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
THAT WAS NOT PART OF HOW IT
OPERATED. IT OPERATED TO CREATE
THE A RESOURCE TO BE ABLE TO
REDO THE INTERSECTIONS, BECAUSE
IT WAS A LEVEL OF SERVICES
INTERSECTION. DELAY OF TRAFFIC.
RIGHT. AND SO IT WAS THE
INTERSECTION THAT GOT UPGRADED,
NOT THE, THE STREET WIDENING. IT
PROVIDED YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A PROTECTED LEFT HAND TURN.
SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE BIG LANES
BACKING UP OR A RIGHT HAND TURN
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THE OTHER
SIDE HAS A LEFT HAND TURN IT. IT
PROVIDED THESE SAFETY FEATURES
AND EXTRA AN EXTRA LANE RIGHT
THERE. SO I'M I'M STRUGGLING
WITH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
THIS IS TOO BROAD OR IF IT'S, IF
IT IF IT WORKS. ANYWAY, THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. I THINK I HAVE A RESPONSE,
AND I'LL ALSO SEE IF KIRSTEN
WANTS TO ADD ANYTHING, BUT I
GUESS WHAT I'LL SAY. SO OUR BILL
IN ITS, I THINK MAYBE ITS
STRONGEST FORM APPLIES TO AREAS
WITHIN TRANSIT PRIORITY AREAS.
SO THESE ARE AREAS MAJOR TRANSIT
STOPS IN, IN OTHER WORDS. AND SO
I THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
SEE IS WHEN THERE IS THESE KIND
OF LEVEL OF SERVICE
DETERMINATIONS MADE IN THESE
AREAS THAT ARE INHERENTLY
TRANSIT ORIENTED, WALKABLE, SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN THE POWERPOINT ARE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WERE LITERALLY
DEVELOPED AROUND AN LA METRO
STOP, AND THE PROBLEM THAT I
THINK THAT WE SEE IS THAT THOSE
LEVELS YOU ANSWERED THE QUESTION
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
ANY TRANSIT ORIENTED CENTERS,
WITH EXCEPTION OF FRESNO, AND
THAT I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
YOU, BUT I KNOW, BUT THAT'S THE
ANSWER THAT I WAS STRUGGLING
WITH, IS THAT THESE THESE
TRANSIT ORIENTED CORRIDORS, I
TOTALLY AGREE THAT WE OUGHT TO
BE GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
VEHICLES AND TAKING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, AND THAT'S
PROBABLY THE WORST PLACE TO BE,
FOOLING AROUND WITH TRAFFIC
MITIGATION MEASURES. BUT AND SO
ANYWAY, THAT'S THAT'S IT. YOU
ANSWERED IT. THANK YOU. I WAS
JUST GOING TO ADD THAT WE DID
MEET WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES,
AND THEY, THEY DID NOT FEEL LIKE
THIS WAS TAKING AWAY ANY, ANY
IMPORTANT TOOLS FROM THEM AND
DIDN'T THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
MAJOR OBJECTIONS TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTEZ. MEMBER CARILLO,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. AND I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION. I THINK OFTENTIMES
AS, AS MEMBERS THAT COME FROM
BIG CITIES AND DON'T REPRESENT
RURAL AREAS, CAN OFTEN JUST
THINK ABOUT IT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. BUT WE HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING TO URBAN COMMUNITIES,
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AND I
THINK THE ITEM NUMBER FOUR ON
THE POLICY ON THE ANALYSIS
READS, IT REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT PROJECTS
LOCATED WITHIN ONE MILE OF A
TRANSIT STATION HAVE A DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE TRANSIT STATION
ALONG A BARRIER FREE WALKING
PATHWAY TO RECEIVE THE LOWER
TRAFFIC IMPACT MITIGATION FEES,
AND REPLACES IT WITH A
REQUIREMENT THAT PROJECTS BE IN
A TPA. SO A TRANSIT PRIORITY
AREA, WHICH, SENATOR I, I THINK,
ANSWERS THE QUESTION IN TERMS OF
HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT IT ON A
LARGER PERSPECTIVE. AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY, I HOPE THAT AREAS
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED,
ESPECIALLY WITH FOLKS MOVING TO
DIFFERENT AREAS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE BAY
OR THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES. I HOPE THAT THE
LOCAL PLANNING COMMITTEES ALSO
LOOK AT THIS POLICY AND ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE ALL THE STATE
POLICIES THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD
THAT ARE REQUIRING DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS OUT OF NEW AREAS
AND NEW NEIGHBORHOODS AND NEW
CITIES THAT ARE BEING BUILT SO
THAT THEY'RE BUILT WITH A
PERSPECTIVE THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO WALK, TO WORK AND
LIVE IN WALKABLE COMMUNITIES AND
BE ABLE TO RIDE A BIKE AND BE
SAFE AND BE ABLE TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSIT. I HOPE TO LIVE IN A
CITY LIKE THAT ONE DAY MYSELF.
LOS ANGELES IS A BEAUTIFUL
PLACE, AND WE HAVE, TRANSIT,
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. BUT IT IS
DIFFICULT TO CONNECT IT. SO YOU
CAN TAKE A BUS SOMEWHERE, BUT
YOU CAN'T GET A BUS SOMEWHERE
ELSE. YOU CAN TAKE METRO, BUT
YOU CAN'T TAKE METRO COMING
BACK. AND IT'S A IT'S A REALITY
THAT I THINK OUR CITY IS ALSO
TRYING TO FIX A WHOLE OTHER
CONVERSATION. BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CREATE SAFE, WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THIS IS ONE STEP FORWARD TO
JUST ALLEVIATE THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBER
CARILLO. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER, OTRO BOGUE. NÓ
OTRO BOGUE. NO. BLAKE, SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER, I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR. PADILLA PADILLA I
CIERTO. CIERTO NO. UMBERG I
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 6
TO 2. WE HAVE 62. WE'LL KEEP
THAT OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING. WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLL. TO FROM THE BEGINNING.
YEAH, WE'LL START FOR THE. OKAY.
SO WE'LL START WITH THE CONSENT
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0 WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING.
AYE. SENATOR UMBERG AYE. UMBERG
AYE. 10 TO 0. OKAY, I'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN. THAT'S OUT. OH IT'S
OUT. OKAY THAT ONE IS OUT. WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE OR BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 930. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO
UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE. 7 TO 2.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ONE OPEN. 7 TO 2. WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
2553 BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 7 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
MENGIBAR CIERTO. NO SERRATO, NO
UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE. IT'S 8 TO 1
AND WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN 8 TO 1.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR UPS
AND MEMBERS. FILE ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 2712 BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE FOR THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATOR MENGIBAR UMBERG I UMBERG
I 7 TO 2. I WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN, FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 1820 BY
MEMBER CHEVELLE. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR CABALLERO CABALLERO.
AYE. MENGIBAR. PADILLA. PADILLA
I CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG I
UMBERG I WAHAB WAHHAB I 9 TO 0.
THAT'S 9 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN. OUR ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
2022 BY MEMBER ADIS. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING SENATOR CHOBOQ
MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA I
CIERTO CIERTO NO UMBERG I UMBERG
I WAHAB WAHAB I 7 TO 1, 7 TO 1.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB 2729 BY MEMBER
JOE PATTERSON. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0, WITH THE CHAIR NOT VOTING AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SKINNER BREAKSPEAR
BREAKSPEAR I MENGIBAR CIERTO
CIERTO I UMBERG I UMBERG I WAHAB
WAHAB I DID YOU SAY NOT VOTING?
YOU ALREADY VOTED. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S 8 TO 0, 8 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN AND WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN, WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 2485
BY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED,
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SKINNER MENGIBAR
PADILLA. PADILLA. I SERRATO
SERRATO I UMBERG I UMBERG I
WAHAB WAHHAB I. IT'S 8 TO 0 AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN AND WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OUR MPS. AND
MEMBERS WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2488 BY
MEMBER TING. A MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
SENATOR OKUBO. NO OKUBO. NO.
MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA I
CIERTO. CIERTO. NO UMBERG I
UMBERG I WAHAB. WAHAB I 7 TO 2.
7 TO 2. AND WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR OUR MEMBERS. DID
YOU SAY WAS THAT A. YOU WERE. IS
THAT FOR THAT WAS THE TING TING
2488. OKAY. PERFECT. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12 AB 2593 BY MEMBER
MCCARTY. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FOR THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 8 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SKINNER. UMBERG
AYE. UMBERG AYE. 9 TO 0. AND
WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN. AND WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW
CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
16, AB 3688 BY MEMBER HANEY. OH,
DID I MISS ONE I APOLOGIZE, THAT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM NUMBER 13, AB
2910 BY MEMBER SANTIAGO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE.
PADILLA PADILLA I UMBERG. AYE
UMBERG I WAHAB. WAHAB AYE. WAS
10 TO 0 AND THE BILL IS OUT
OKAY. THAT'S 10 TO 0. AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 3068 BY
MEMBER HANEY. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED. AND WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE UMBERG.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WAHHAB. AYE.
THAT'S EIGHT TO DO. AND THE BILL
IS OUT 8 TO 2. AND THAT BILL IS
OUT. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ITEM
NUMBER 17 AB 3093 BY MEMBER WARD
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING SENATOR CHOBOQ
MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
SERRATO SERRATO NO. UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE.
THAT'S 7 TO 1 AND WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON THE CALL. 7 TO 1 AND WE'LL
KEEP THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 3177 BY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO, I THINK
WE VOTED. OH, THAT ONE'S DONE.
OKAY, SO WE'RE GOOD WITH THAT,
OKAY. WE'LL NOW, YOU CAN PUT US
ON A RECESS. OKAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A RECESS UNTIL OUR
OUR LAST MEMBERS COME BACK.
THANK YOU.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
WILL COME OUT OF RECESS. SO
WE'RE BACK IN ORDER. WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE ROLL, AND, WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH, I WAS HERE
FOR ITEM ONE. OH, YES. YES. SO
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE LIFTING
THE ROLL ON THOSE BILLS. THAT
AND THEN WE'LL CLOSE IT.
OKAY. SO WE ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ON A NUMBER OF
BILLS, EVEN ONES I VOTED ON, SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT CLEAR ON THE
RECORD THAT THE BILL IS PASSED
AND IT'S OUT. SO WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER ONE AB 930 AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 7 TO 2. SENATOR MENGIBAR
AND THAT'S IT. ALL RIGHT. AB 930
IS OUT. VOTE IS 7 TO 2. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM TWO AB 20 553.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 1. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT AB 2553 IS
OUT AND THE VOTE IS 8 TO 1.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE AB 2712.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 2.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT. AB
2712 IS OUT 7 TO 2. WE'LL GO TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WAS ALREADY
CLOSED, SO WE WILL NOT REOPEN
THAT. WE WILL GO TO ITEM FIVE AB
1820 AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0.
SENATOR MENGIBAR RIGHT. AB 1820
IS OUT 9 TO 0. WE'LL GO TO ITEM
SIX AB 2022. CURRENT VOTE IS 7
TO 1. SENATOR BOGUE, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL
IS OUT AB 2022 WITH THE SEVEN
ZERO VOTE. WE'LL GO TO ITEM 7 TO
1 VOTE. EXCUSE ME, AB 2022 7 TO
1 VOTE. WE'LL GO TO ITEM EIGHT
AB 2729. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 8
TO 0. SENATOR SKINNER. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. MENGIBAR 9 TO 0.
ALL RIGHT. AB 2729 IS OUT. 9 TO
0. WE'LL GO TO NINE AB 2485.
CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 0. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
MENGIBAR 9 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. SO,
AB 2485 IS OUT, 9 TO 0. WE'LL GO
TO ITEM TEN AB 2488 CURRENT 7 TO
2. SENATOR MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT
THEN AB 2488 IS OUT. 7 TO 2.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM 12 AB 2593.
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE. 10
TO 0 AB 2593 IS OUT. 10 TO 0.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER 13 AB 2910.
BE CLOSED OUT. WE ALREADY CLOSED
IT. ALL RIGHT. AB 2910 CLOSED
WITH. JUST TELL ME THAT VOTE.
AYE. 10 TO 0, 10 TO 0. SO WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM 15. CORRECT?
NOPE. WE'LL GO TO ITEM 16.
EXCUSE ME. ITEM 16. THAT WAS
THAT CLOSED OUT OR IS IT 8 TO 2.
SO IT'S CLOSED OUT. SO ITEM 16
AB 36 TO 8 WAS CLOSED OUT 88 TO
2 WILL GO TO 17. ITEM 17 AB
3093. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CURRENT VOTE OF 7 TO 1.
SENATOR BORG. SENATOR MENGIBAR 7
TO 1 AB 3093 IS OUT 7 TO 1.
WE'LL NOW GO TO, ITEM 18 AB
3177. CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 2.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. MENGIBAR 7 TO 2. ALL RIGHT.
AB 3177 IS OUT. 7 TO 2. AND WITH
THAT, THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL BE ADJOURNED.